from swing jumping studios in the heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
movie fights now your host Andy signor
today's episode is presented by t-mobile
America's best unlimited network hello
and welcome to the championship versus
Mike Botanic as Carlson gonna be both
here one-on-one had miss up and it's
gonna be full of surprises they don't
know that I've helped judging this
episode it's gonna be a lot of fun so
get excited and stay tuned we have five
awesome battles lots of stuff happening
you want to stay engaged on Twitter
which line is on following on the feeds
at s J at screen junkies on Twitter you
guys will be at home helping to vote for
this show that's right where I'll
explain as we go but get excited make
sure you're logged in there and make
sure your comment in the comments we're
here live on YouTube for everybody let's
do this
before I introduce everybody I want to
get our fighters out here because that's
what you guys are waiting for and these
guys are awesome they're gonna be
fighting awesome stuff such as best
movie trilogy of all time pitch a movie
based on a commercial and of course the
most asks for battle ET vs. jaws it's
their favorite film so we're gonna get
all through this and again follow along
hashtag movie fights live hashtag movie
fights live on Twitter to get engaged in
the conversation first up let's meet our
fighters guys he's had a long journey to
get here and he's actually trying to
take the belt from Dan before he didn't
get it but now he's hopped up for blood
it's Botanica themself ladies and
gentlemen Mike
[Applause]
and Baxter you on the camera that would
be a lot more helpful there we go thanks
Mike welcome in hey awesome tehani dude
we're gonna be here cool great Mike how
are you feeling
I miss battle I really like I'm feeling
stressed out the show is cray it's
horrible to do the show it is there's so
much prep there's so much but this the
stakes I mean my goodness you look like
Tony Stark thank you wow I feel good
again
alright gay I'm good I'm ready to go
ladies and gentlemen he's gonna have to
get that belt the hard way he's gonna
have to go through the current champ of
so many belts
[Applause]
[Music]
dan tend to the camera where JT cuts to
the camera there like first time you've
done this
let's go let's go down I just won that
one that's TV fight sing on
one seconds happening like I see moving
fights about I've spended that like six
I here we go this one is stuck to the TV
fights both there we go
- how many belts is that that's a lot of
belts the belt is on the line I'm gonna
put these over here for safekeeping Mike
you can't have these well I actually
don't want them because I took from my
girlfriend's closet earlier no I can't
do that she'll be very upset with me but
these are cream that max that's not
framed very well sorry here they are
they're just a little bit see max oats
for a lady but ya know if I lose these
are coming home with me pretty belts I
gotta say yeah you guys have all brought
some very fantastic belts but this is
the one that Dan covets and I will take
it Dan no I don't have it are you
putting this on the line Dan oh it's on
the line cuz you have to it wasn't a
choice well I've been waiting to put it
on the line for a long time this belt is
fine no a lot of friends like finally
it's up there and I'm so excited to do
this it's gonna find it's gonna put on
the floor
alright here's how the show's gonna work
guys we got a lot of intense stuff
happening but I want to introduce what's
going on here before we do it the way
this vote this the show will go be done
is not just by my sole vote Oh a lot of
fans were like come on this is the
championship step it up Andy I listened
and I did so this fan this is his phone
will be decided partly by the fans
that's right you guys at home on Twitter
you will be voting at the end of each
round on Twitter to deem who wins now
this is not a popularity contest as Dan
as sometimes pointed out at home we are
not gonna say who the fight is who the
fighter is or what their answer was it's
gonna be 1 & 2 and that way only the
ones watching or just people who want to
be dicks and be random in Co vote for
option 1 or 2 at the end of each round
and I will be taking that into a chord
you will have a say in this fight so
make sure your on Twitter all along to
check out our polls and vote along the
show so you can help us decide who wins
this belt but that's not it guys I've
also brought in an expert can we go over
to San Catch
second series lawn Harris Halon you'll
be fact-checking today's show can't wait
very excited and you'll be also police
in making sure Twitter's here but right
next to you is it will find gentlemen
he's from harvard-westlake he's the
debate coach ladies and gentlemen to
michael beets oh so no Michael we talk a
fortune you're not a huge nerd you don't
know a lot about movies I love this so
you are gonna be helping me today you
are only about the arguments yes sir
we've talked about this dissuasion the
persuasion etc but I want you to help me
try because you will have a say in this
fight as well
strict debate who gave the best debate
you can't let your personal take involve
because you won't have one you're gonna
be listening to the argument yes what do
you guys think of that does that make
you more nervous or more excited Mike
and Dan if if he's judging does he take
silly nonsense into account okay then
yes okay guys I feel fine yeah yeah yeah
great good all right good
also we have a huge awesome fan cam over
there let's tune into all of our studio
audience check it out or someone missing
you slide over there's a big empty spot
looks much better
did someone leave I was someone left oh
sorry some what they missed a show Wow
Andrew amar to Dakota at Donald dizzle
Dan Moody who didn't show up
thanks max is cool doesn't matter we're
not live or anything all right and rude
and shrimp thanks man so amar Dakota
dizzle and moody thank you guys for
coming here you guys will also be
chiming in throughout the fight if I
need help you guys ready for this how
excited are you guys good you have the
mic you'll be spreading I didn't know so
it's seven points I'll be also gay so
this is the fans are engaged we have a
real-life debate coach here lawns also
helping me this is a legit fight nothing
can be asked afterwards if that wasn't
fair we got all ball bases corner you
guys follow what's happening here
any questions before we get to this show
can we start yes yes Mike I was just
gonna can we stop now before we go I do
have to say something very special we'll
be down at Comic Con next week cover in
San Diego so you can head over to screen
Huggies news on YouTube to watch all the
interviews and stuff we have planned so
much stuff in store but I want to let
you know that screen Nicky Central's
coming back we have tickets they
actually sold out in a day which was
crazy thank you guys so much but we just
opened up some more tickets so if you
show up in San Diego at the event itself
and get there early we will have some
tickets available and also a waiting
list that you'll be able to get to so
even if you have tickets get there early
to all that information can be found on
screen Rocky's comm slash tickets which
hopefully will pop up if not screened oh
geez calm slash tickets to learn all
this information if you aren't in
Kissimmee ago don't worry we'll also be
streaming a lot of this from central
over in screen Nucky's news and screen
Okies mane over the next couple weeks so
bottom line stay tuned lots of fun stuff
and stored for screen no keys at Comic
Con and I got to thank t-mobile so much
for helping make this happen they're
America's best unlimited network they
helped pull this off and I'm so grateful
for this to happen they've also really
helped us not bring a lot of shows it'll
be coming on the screen dokie screen
hockey's news in the coming week so stay
tuned tomorrow you'll be to watch us
live as well dan flick bait is moving
from news to the main channel of man 4
p.m. here you guys are gonna love it
it's so much fun come check it out with
us and then SJ you will be coming as a
new morning show on News with Dan myself
Spencer Roth cornet every morning
starting on Tuesday 718 at 11:00 a.m.
but Monday Spencer's there with watching
Thrones you can learn all about these
changes but the most important one
that's gonna affect you is movie fights
is gonna be live here on YouTube every
Thursday what we're live right now we're
live right now I'll be doing this more
stay tuned guys get excited because this
will become a reoccurring thing or all
of you will be able to join us every
Thursday to tune in to movie fights live
I'm so excited for you to have an
experienced fans you know what it's like
right how fun is movie fights live
guys will love watching home live it's
so much fun to engage at LAN we'll be
tracking you that's all I got let's do
this Wow I love that intro love it
alright let's do this the fight the belt
is on the line
round one now guys we did something
previously that the fans really liked we
thought it would be only fair to bring
it back this time you will each be
giving an advantage question to each
other that means you both have the
opportunity to pick a question yourself
that you thought would give you a bit of
an advantage that you can answer first
prompting your competitor to have to
answer second Dan you got the first
advantage round and the round you picked
was best hitchhike Hitchcock movie yes I
could have I could have said that way
more embarrassingly no best Hitchcock
movie was the one you brought this is
your advantage what movie did you pick I
picked rear-window
great which i think is both of the best
Alfred Hitchcock movie and is also my
favorite Alfred Hitchcock movie and it's
really tough because Advocate Hitchcock
has so many great movies and you could
pick 10 movies and argue about like why
they're great so I think it's really put
into this thing which not just why these
are two great movies and I'm sure Mike's
pick is great too but why I think this
is the best and the reason that I
connects rear windows so much with
Alfred Hitchcock is because it hits on
this theme that Alfred Hitchcock has in
so many of his movies voyeurism and
obsession these are things that he comes
back to all the times sometimes it's the
main theme of his movies sometimes it's
part of the elements was movie but it's
its present and almost every movie that
he made and what I love about
rear-window is that instead of seeing
his characters as warriors instead of
the audience watching a movie in which a
character is a lawyer Alfred Hitchcock
puts the audience in the shoes of the
protagonist if you haven't seen it James
Stewart plays a photographer who has a
broken leg he's confined to his
apartment and he has this big a window
that looks out on a courtyard he can see
all of his neighbors and he starts to
think that the neighbor across the way
has murdered his wife
and what I love about this is this movie
doesn't tell you that the neighbor
across the way murdered his wife you're
learning through Jimmy Stewart's eyes as
the movie goes on you're learning the
information as he knows it because you
are literally watching along with him
and it's what I think is the best
realization for him of this themes that
he tried to express in so many different
movies here he ultimately succeeds in
putting the audience almost in his shoes
as a filmmaker you're watching this
movie along with the main characters
there's a lot more than I can go into as
far as technical and everything which I
will but that's the main reason why I
picked rear-window
as the best Hitchcock movie all right
Mike best Hitchcock movie all right um
obviously Alfred Hitchcock pretty good
at making movies we can all agree I took
just four just to be full disclosure I
took it out for Hitchcock class in
college and I got a b-minus in it so if
your guys are blown away by what I do
here I'm sorry it makes sense I've
chosen notorious 1946 notorious now this
is probably this now this is some
people's favorite Hitchcock movie but
it's often times I feel like forgotten
maybe cuz it's in black and white maybe
because it came out a little bit before
sort of like his big blockbuster phase
but here I'll do a quick recap quick so
when you're Ingrid Bergman plays a woman
she's enlisted by the government to
infiltrate Nazis Cary Grant is like her
contact and he because she because her
father is a Nazi she's the perfect
person to go and infiltrate and learn
you know what the Nazis evil plans are
so before this mission happens Cary
Grant falls in love with Ingrid Bergman
so it's very complicated when she gets
entangled and has to essentially act as
a honeypot
for an evil Nazi which would end which
ends up having her marry this guy and
carry on a relationship this movie is
the best of all the Hitchcock movies
because it's not just suspenseful and
it's not just filled with like
hair-raising moments this is emotional
suspense this is relationship horror the
this is a love triangle of like the
worst most perverse kind you have Cary
Grant playing a character who
passive-aggressive and mean and instead
of being loving and supportive when this
woman needs him the most and then you
have Claude Rains honestly one of the
more sympathetic characters in the movie
married to a woman who does not love him
who a man who wishes this woman would
just earnestly love him this is
something that goes deeper than most
Hitchcock movies most Hitchcock movies
are amazing attention and thrills this
thing goes even deeper this gets to the
core of its characters more than any
other Hitchcock movie rear-window is
like a great movie but the conflicts and
the story and the themes of notorious go
deeper and offer the viewer like a more
complex and ultimately rewarding
experience all right now great oh and
start this fight but just so the
audience at home because I forgot to
mention because it's in the manager
round Mike if you win this round you get
an extra point and then Mike will get an
advantage round next point next round
and then Danny if you win Mike's a
veteran you will get an extra point that
said I got that out of the way fight it
out guys here's the thing about
notorious I rewatched it last night
because it's been a while since I saw it
and for some reason the Tuohy's is one
of those movies that I and maybe this is
me not being as you know as familiar as
I should be but I get it confused with
spellbound and suspicion and like I feel
like that's part of an era of Hitchcock
movies that with Cary Grant that people
are kind of like which one is that like
I had to think for a second which one is
in choice but I went back and rewatch it
because I don't want to rely just on
that and I found it to be like you're
right the movie does is the plot does
rely on the character connections but I
felt like you know Ingrid Bergman and
Cary Grant they meet they fly to Rio
she's conflicted and then literally
within 30 seconds they're just like
walking up a hill and then they kiss and
now they're in love all of a sudden and
the Cary Grant doesn't care about her
and he's a total dick throughout the
entire movie and but then he's not and I
just felt like the character shifts were
not handled very well in that movie that
could have been handled better I felt
like Hitchcock was a little more
concerned with the themes and the
technical aspects than the characters
and I think so much the plot relies on
that that that's kind of the weak point
it's a bit of a slow start to kind of
get you into it I would argue though
that the characters in this movie are
actually like more fleshed out and a lot
deeper than a lot of the characters in
those other movies because like we
already set up that Ingrid Bergman's
character is like promiscuous whatever
that means but like especially in the
time that it was made women were judged
very harshly for that so you've already
set her up sort of maybe as having sort
of an erratic life social life and Cary
Grant like he doesn't admit that he
loves this woman until the end of the
movie until she's been through the
friggin wringer like like this they do
have this quick romance but like it
makes sense in the context of who these
characters are and what we've set up for
them in the past
so I guess it's something in the rear
window I feel like we sort of just get
like a cool playboy kind of Jimmy
Stewart character that doesn't dig as
deep into who is psyche who he is and
what a psyche is as we do in this movie
see that that's and but I think
rear-window in a way addresses the
characters relationship a little bit
more because you have Jimmy Stewart you
have Grace Kelly and kind of what the
movie is about I mean it's what the last
shot of the movie is about is Jimmy
Stewart is this kind of thrill-a-minute
photographer who has this girlfriend
who's kind of sending like I want to get
married but you won't settle down and
and stay with me and and he and she's
saying can I at least go with you and
he's saying like this is not the life
for you you don't want to be part of
this and through the course of that
movie they both kind of learn to see
from the other ones vantage point Jimmy
Stewart kind of learns the lesson of
listen if you go out looking for this
kind of excitement you know what one of
these days it's gonna come finding you
and he almost dies at the end because of
it Grace Kelly getting involved in that
also almost dies and I feel like by the
end of that they really develop those
two characters relationship through the
events of the movie in a much deeper way
than I found in notorious which to me
seemed like the plot required them to
feel certain ways I feel like rear
window and telling this murder mystery
also kind of takes these characters full
circle and that's ultimately what the
movie is about is about these two people
kind of being exposed to the worst of
each others worlds and learning that hey
you know I understand you a little
better and the implication being that
that they can now be together because of
the events in this film so it I think it
does kind of combine suspense terror
mystery a romantic angle in a more
cohesive way than I think notorious did
well I mean I think as far as Jimmy
Stewart's character in real window the
way I read it is this is a guy who's
just like wants to get laid some more
like he's a guy who just wants to see
other girl like he's giving all these
reasons and intellectualizing things but
if you really look through if I knew
this guy and he was like telling if my
friend was like hey my photographer
boyfriend doesn't want to get married
cuz he you know he gave me this laundry
list of reasons I'd be like oh he well
he wants to be single still like he's
running her
round III think that the character is a
lot less deep and like as what you're
saying like the characters in Taurus are
erratic like the movie does not resolve
the movie is a lot more complex you're
the one who has to go on the journey
like they don't resolve it and get
married at the end of this movie like
there's a resolution in the sense that
you know Cary Grant says I love you and
Ingrid Bergman is like why didn't you
say that before why would you just not
say that like we end on a note of like
he does rescue her but this is not a
happy ending for these two characters
like I think that's like a much more
interesting way to sort of resolve
something than making it sort of like
wrapped up in a nice little package I
don't know I just think that it's
telling a more complete story the
characters is what appeals to me more
than just again kind of the back and
forth the swing I didn't really find
myself rooting for Cary Grant's at all I
didn't want him to know kind of come out
on top and I feel like the movie kind of
they played this in part as kind of a
triumphant moment I'm like the movie
didn't I don't think that his character
got to service that it needed but apart
from character I saw him talk about with
rear-window because that's part of it I
think storing character part of it I'm
talking to the technically why I think
this is Hitchcock's best movie cuz it's
completely apart from a story angle from
a technical angle what he did in
building that set and again and showing
that that entire movie takes place in
one room and you don't even realize it
because you're constantly moving around
the entire movie takes place in his
apartment it does not feel
claustrophobic for a second and what he
did in constructing the set and
choreographing everything just from a
technical directing angle how he got all
of that action to tell that story and
shot it from so many different angles
over so many days and brought you into
that world so completely I think beyond
even the story aspect technically I
think this is a superior film as well
well I mean as far as visual I mean look
this guy knows what he's doing visually
before yeah believe it or not this guy
knows who to hire to make his movies
look good cuz guy yeah there's in the
tour I mean if you want to talk about
beautiful shots and Tori says this
amazing crane shot that cranes down into
the middle of this party and Ingrid
Bergman is holding a key and like it
makes you see oh wow this part but all
it comes down to is that she has stolen
this key to the wine cellar which has
uranium I did research I looked at other
critics
Roger Ebert said Alfred Hitchcock
centuries-- is the most elegant
expression of the Masters visual style
and God bless Roger Ebert I he's he
knows what he knows what he's talking
about I think that like yeah rear window
is great like
he's made this movie look like he's done
a lot with a very small space but I
think isn't Tori's the shots I mean the
the framing of things from the start of
when she's hungover and there's a glass
with alka-seltzer in it and then exactly
the same shot comes later
with a glass with arsenic in it when
she's being poisoned like these are
amazing beautiful things that callback
like stuff you wouldn't necessarily
notice on the first watch these are
things that make the movie a rich more
rewarding experience if you come back to
it over it all right I'm trying to keep
this loose because it's a championship
fella but now it's time for final
closing arguments get against tell me
your last closing here why is
rear-window the better film / notorious
and then Mike tell me why notorious is
the better film over a rear window here
we go well for me it comes down kind of
to what Mike was saying and what you see
a lot of people talk about the toys they
talk about that shot with the key the
shot with the glass the shot and I feel
like there are a lot of great shots in
notorious I feel like if you look at
some of the stuff for the time people
like wow that was a really good shot I
think that rear-window
more than having great shots it was the
style it was the expression of Hitchcock
as an auteur and and living through his
eyes and him being putting the audience
into his shoes and living this world as
a voyeur and him kind of expressing his
own psyche that to me nothing says
Hitchcock more than that and the fact
that he was able to do that to make a
movie that was funny because there are
funny jokes that was a mystery that
still holds up to this day I think it is
as and compelling as it was the day that
it came out is the murder mystery it is
a thriller it is genuinely scary at the
end with Raymond Burr it has all of
these elements of a great film plus the
ability to take his own personal style
and intent and marry it to that story so
well and express it so well I cannot
think of another film to me that Alfred
Hitchcock put his personal stamp on more
than rear-window and that's why I think
it's his best mic final thoughts first
of all I want to say as far as I were
you watching notorious when we were
watching her window and notorious does
not have in my mind a bad beat in it
rear window has an ending that's kind of
doesn't age well because he like clicks
the camera and there's a flash and it
like keeps the bad guy at bay for like a
good 60 seconds and it's just kind of
goofy and I feel like it should be
docked points for that
that being said look these are both good
movies but I think the notorious
is in the when you look at all of his
work is almost an anomaly isn't is a
much more interesting look a guy this is
the time when he actually wanted to go
deeper this is something when he wanted
to do characters that weren't so sort of
archetypes or like characters is a
little harsh but I'll say characters
this is something where this is a movie
that I think is the most interesting of
his career and I look if you won't we
feel and ultramel quote some more famous
smart people Francois Truffaut called
out for Hitchcock sutorius the
quintessential Hitchcock film Truffaut
knows what he's doing folks
but I will sum up with this and these
are my own words rear window is a great
right it is great it is thrilling it
suspenseful but notorious is a greater
deeper richer more experience a deeper
experience while watching it as a film
Wow I gotta say Mike really surprised me
there and brought some serious [ __ ]
knowledge I did not expect so that was a
really tough fight for me at lon let's
go to you first while Mike gathers his
thoughts I'll come to you Mike next but
long what do they say online yeah and
also the poll will now be up so go vote
sorry one for Mike to for Dan one for
Mike to for Dan no popularity here you
have to watch the show again it's about
the arguments guys it's not what you
like try and really get in my shoes cuz
you always complain about it now's your
chance to be the judge it's harder than
you think
lon what do you think is saying psycho
came up a lot strangers on a train
spellbound North by a lot of people
pushing for psycho and then other people
yelling at them that they should watch
more Hitchcock movies assuming that we
haven't that was a lot of the back end
bragging in the Twitter no no I mean I
mean on Twitter and then a lot of people
were suggesting the birds and then a lot
of people were yelling at them that that
is his worst movie so there was a lot of
discussion those side discussion going
on also a lot of people took issue with
calling notorious Hitchcock's most
personal film a lot of suggestions for
what that might have been maybe Marni
maybe vertigo personally for me I mean I
think this is a really hard one to to
judge the only argument that that I
didn't really love that we heard was the
I get it mixed up a lot of people on
Twitter backed up like oh I also get it
make
stuff with suspicion or saboteurs some
of the others like I don't I don't know
I I don't have a trouble keeping it
notorious different from like spellbound
which is Gregory Peck or something so I
know if I was really won over than that
but otherwise a really intense round
really tough to judge all right now Mike
as a debate coach I'd love to get your
thoughts based on that argument who do
you think won and why well that's a
debate coach what I do is I look and see
what arguments go unanswered first and
figure out if those are persuasive in
the argument that I feel like is dropped
is at the very beginning about rear
window where we talked about taking the
audience into the eyes of the of the
characters yes being Ames yes and that
argument I feel like those everything
else
I feel like gets addressed back and
forth with no real resolution that
single argument though kind of carries
through that that's the best that that
that that is why this is the best movie
because it's a Burin his shoes really
experiencing with them I I said it was a
ride but your take was they because I
the word I'm having trouble out so I
want to get your things it didn't really
feel like they were hitting each other
back and forth back and forth I would
say as a piece of advice you need to you
need to figure out how to resolve those
when they're just when you're just going
back and forth how do I decide yeah how
to decide between two conflicting things
all right that's great I'm gonna give
them delaying is I want the fans in the
comments I'm gonna go to the outside to
the fans over there who was listening
who wants to chime in Lamar who gave me
something good tomorrow who gave the
best argument here but this is very hard
I think Dan got it for pure passion and
I liked his arguments dizzle oh yeah go
ahead I would say it's a nail-biter
because both good movies a lot of people
like both movies I like both movies but
hearing the arguments based I would have
to say mark gave a better argument with
I mean more you know with it and okay
yeah I would just say give a better
argument with it yeah dizzle um I gotta
go Dan because what he said about us
being the viewer and then being on the
ride and I love movies real quick
I'm not gonna lie I've never heard of
Victorious until right now but Mike
actually did a really good job of
selling me on the movie but I think that
me Dan had a little more passion
all right so everyone's leading towards
Dan let's say what are the vote on the
audience what poll where we at lawns are
close enough to say a winner it is
extraordinarily close yeah I just
refreshed so we can hopefully get not so
I have 51% to 49% Wow we want to let it
play how many people weighing in yeah
279 total votes so sounds like you gave
them two blind options that they weren't
sure which to pick from one and I told
them one - yeah
all right so who's leading by the fifty
one option one Mike Carlson leads 51% to
Denver option to 49% is like Florida oh
man all right here's arrived stand
because it looks like it looks like
they're leaning towards Dan though at
the fans and I had the debate coach both
picked the fans in the room but then
they so it really does come out of me I
it's surprisingly I heard a lot it's
Mike surprised me whether that's fair or
not he really came with armed facts back
and I think being that that he was the
disadvantaged one here I gave him a
little bit of an edge just because I was
very impressed he was able to take you
toe to toe in your advantage run Dan
that said I did make a note also the
protagonist shoes is really one thing
it's like that is a very good reason and
there wasn't anything as iconic from
that from your argument Mike that made
me sway to like oh yeah you did do a
very good job that what making me feel
good about notorious and I was like
interesting but I'm gonna go with sort
of the fans in the room and Mike to sway
me a little bit towards Dan just because
I think that was a very strong point
that didn't get addressed so I'm gonna
give Dan the first points
[Applause]
all right but Mike it's your turn for
your advantage rats I'm so excited
Mike you had a choice to pick any
question and you chose to pitch it
Botanica s-- solo movie
that's correct yes all right so you want
to pitch a Botanica solo movie Mike go
ahead you get tougher so let's because
that's the some people are probably new
so I probably have to let people know
who Botanica says just in case just in
case so on the ET ride at Universal
Studios there's an important figure
Steven Spielberg is the one who taught
talks about him hit and he tells you
that you need to get et home to the
Green Planet which is where he lives
because he needs he's gotten a distress
call from his teacher Botanica Stevens
calls him and we see botanic but
Botanica says Steven says and he's a
very important figure now I am what you
would say obsessed with him there is a
book about him there are there's
actually a video game that came out a
couple years ago that it was no longer
available for iOS unfortunately I tried
to get it but it they pulled it probably
because it was bad but that doesn't mean
the character is bad so bow Tanic
Botanica says I've been calling him is
et's teachers so this is an ET spinoff
essentially okay all right so I take you
to brodo as so G which is the real name
of ETS planet aka the green planet
interior small classroom now there are
unruly kids you know these are kids that
are bad they're throwing paper airplanes
they're setting off you know whatever
the brodo is og bottle rocket version is
okay
there's characters that are real by the
way named flop flop gobble which is real
that is cannon there's a character named
orbit Don he's in there - he's messing
around now a substitute teacher in that
class says hey settle down now one
student lights up a space cigarette and
says shove it old lady now we zoom in
and the student is a young et a ka shrek
zr e k which is his cannon real name
zurich zr e ka and now this is the et
from obviously the movie ET and the
substitute teacher runs away because
this has happened over and over again
subject to teachers try to deal with
this class
but they can't cuz these kids are so out
of control well who can deal with these
unruly kids enter a young college press
a professor Botanica s' he comes in he
flips the chair backwards he sits down
and he says playtime is over
main titles Botanica Dangerous Minds o
Botanica s-- teaches young ET and all
these students how to be great well yes
okay prequel for eating before ET
teaches all of these kids how to be
great citizens of brodo as OG aka the
Green Planet does Julio do a song no
okay that was important for me dance
we'll come back and hear more about
Mike's dangerous minds pitch but Dan how
are you turning Botanica Somali I mean
like is Right Botanica s-- is a very
important creature and ET lore of course
I he had an advantage on me as far as
knowledge but I went back and tried to
do as much there's not much out there
about Botanica so the fact that he's and
the et ride yes and that's about it
there's a book there's a book that I
didn't have access to so I decided to
kind of take what I know of Botanica
from what little I was able to read and
what I know of ET and and really I
wanted to construct a really great
adventure because I feel like that's
that's what people want with me T they
want an adventure e t--'s species are
obviously explorers that's how eetzi got
stranded on earth to begin with they
were exploring they were taking samples
so mine does not actually open on their
planet mine opens on a spaceship much
like e t--'s helmed by led by Botanica
hsihu is leading an exploratory mission
out to find other planets other
life-forms other civilizations when the
spaceship crashes they're stranded on
the strange planet the ship is broken
but they're smart and this is what I
loved about ET was like you kind of got
an idea that like his entire race were
kind of scientific geniuses they had all
these powers that you know you think
eighteen didn't make things float but
you never really got into what all they
could do with those powers so I had
Botanica sand his ship crashing on this
planet
he meets a group of villagers there's a
young girl there's her dad who I'm
thinking is like maybe like a like a
Martin Freeman type somebody who can do
like like you know like
human humanoid humanoid kinda like Star
Trek where you go to a planet and
they're there they're mean they're
mostly human but they're alien enough I
think like I'm Martin Freeman could give
you the kind of humble villager type add
a little comedy this isn't a totally
serious thing but it's you know they are
meeting these villagers and they're
basically enlisting their help this is
kind of a pre-industrial Society but
they're scientifically curious and it's
kind of a cultural exchange however
there's a neighboring village that is
threatening their village led by I'm
gonna say like a Christoph Waltz type
very very kind of aggressive type and
basically as they become friends
Botanica sand the the crew of his ship
decide they're going to help save this
village from this neighbouring village
who's trying to attack them and take
things over so the main thing that I
wanted to do is I want to see more of
like what these aliens can do what is
their species capable of I want to get
more into their scientific knowledge and
exploration I want to get more into what
crazy weird powers they have and how
they can be used and I think if you do
that in a sense of like they're making
friends with the species they're
defending this village it's kind of like
the Seven Samurai type thing which is a
classic story and it's one that I think
you can you can do really fun and
basically story of these two cultures
meeting coming together they repair the
spaceship they leave armed with all this
cultural knowledge but it's it's kind of
an expansion on the et lore but you can
also go into some details that we just
touched on on ET and again featuring I
think that Botanica can give you a
strong character one who's more
knowledgeable in ET you don't have that
learning curve that et had he who seemed
kind of young and inexperienced
I think Botanica are gonna jump over
that and you're gonna really learn more
about these species and about him as a
character and a leader and a friend and
a alien well just as I was surprised to
know but Mike had his Hitchcock
knowledge I'm very impressed in how deep
danwon this particular bench that's a
really great start Mike go ahead find it
out I would like to say for the record
though mine is a totally serious thing
okay
unlike Dan's whose frivolous I did I did
forget a one element this is a musical
oh that is a huge thing this is a
musical and if you would indulge me I do
have a guitar and a few pieces of the
music
written by me idea will allow that sure
is this the first musical performance
might on Levites all right Errol I'll go
turn my mics for your guitar oh shoot
[Music]
it's way out of tune let's take some
time tuning that's always good how can I
get my car Odie it's gonna be out of
tune but that's ok ok alright so this
song is when Botanica s-- teaches ET
about healing plants alright so he would
just like kind of put his hand on ET
said and go well there's a plant that's
dying in and it doesn't have a chance
take your hand let it linger
use that magic finger bring it back to
life
go ahead play God so that's one of the
things he would teach ET early on well
if you have more you can use it but I
gotta get Dan in on this I do have more
but we'll come back keep your guitar I
have some problems mainly the fact that
I just as a movie goer and I think as
moviegoers are starting to see I I'm
very tired of the idea of a spin-off
movie being a prequel and showing us
young blank how many times have we seen
young blank and their teacher I think
that's a bit overused as a trope I don't
want to see I don't think we need to see
young et I think I learned more than
enough about ET and the first et movie
we got secondly they don't speak English
which contradicts the ET lore that we
already know so your country
translations translate yeah so it's like
speaking brodo Xue Jian uh-huh of course
okay well then that's that's good
because I was hoping that you weren't
gonna completely cut in you can pretty
much shat upon the et that we already
know I don't know
we do it never say it's serious it
doesn't sound very serious today the
best to me if I'm no no no I will here's
the thing you brought up a great point
I'm glad you did because it's a perfect
intro for the next song you're saying
okay we don't want to see just et young
and I totally agree like we don't want
to just this have this boa et zeorge
it's not ET surgeon at all
that's definitely it's just about a
young ET it's not a but well he's in a
young ET is in the movie but you're also
going
this is focusing on Botanica so you're
getting into things you're getting into
things like his love life so like yeah
there's another teacher at the school
who falls in love with patan I guess
alright and this is kind of like a pop
punk to type song easy tease teacher
he's a smart and thoughtful creature
he'll teach these kids will show them
how to grow cannon kiss the wise when I
look into his eyes I know that he's the
lover that I need
[Music]
but Tana kiss won't you love me you're
the type of man that a woman needs I
want to live with you inside a giant
turnip so it's not just about et it's
also a love story between a female
character named Betty tanika's that
falls in love with you tea's teacher
Botanica I have a question are you so
much also in the native as goujian and
translated yes and how will that work
well I mean I would look bro is o genus
as similar dot like it sounds similar to
English so as far as like obviously it's
not gonna be perfect but the melody is
gonna be the same and yeah there's gonna
have to be a couple different
Corrections when we're translating the
language I totally agree with you of
course yeah and this look as far as
we're doing the stranded thing in your
movie it's stranded it's the exact same
beat is the first one like we're gonna
go get stranded and then we're gonna
introduce a bunch of other characters
we've never been to the green planet
before this movie exclusively is about
the green planet and its inhabitants
okay like why would we want to instead
of just exploring this wonderful world
that we've never seen before movie why
would we go somewhere else and learn a
whole set of new characters if you've
been on the et right you have a lot of
questions about the different characters
like orbit Ron the mushroom man who says
welcome home you've arrived we want to
know more about him we don't need
another character like the Martin
Freeman character the Christoph Waltz
character we want to know about orbit on
orbit Ron maybe you do I don't so much I
don't really get in each ear i'ts not
something that I come out with a lot of
pressing questions no there's not a lot
that has haunted me about it I mean we
can argue about our premises all day as
a movie fan again I'm just a little more
worried this is a prequel musical
serious classroom drama sci fi I I this
just doesn't it just sounds like a real
mess to me it sounds like I want to get
your closing here in gym so again why
why is your film the one that's more
important than dance look absolutely
this is an experimental film that mixes
a lot of different styles on a lot of
different tones it's going to take a
person with a with a skilled hand a
filmmaking hand and a great writer to
make this happen of course I'm the
writer and director
this when it happens and I will know
exactly how to execute it so yeah right
now in the abstract maybe it sounds like
there's a lot but that's because I'm
throwing a lot of different fun elements
at it
things that true et fans that love the
ride that want to know more about the
green planet a quebrado is OG want to
know if you just look down what we said
what do you rather hear fun punk pop pop
punk songs sung by ET aliens or do you
want to just like go to a farm where
Christoph Waltz is like has like bad
Star Trek makeup I mean just look at the
things I've presented and look at the
things that Dan of presented what do you
want to see more first of all you're
finally doing that tactic where you make
your options sound great and you make my
options sound really bad but
oversimplifying it and bringing up
things that you don't like that's what
it's doing an exciting movie fights this
would be an exciting time just calling
you on it this would be an exciting
movie this would be an exciting
adventure sci-fi the way that people are
actually gonna want to go see your movie
will bankrupt a studio I promise you
this it is a complete disaster that no
one will no one will watch it no one
will see it it's gonna lose 200 million
dollars and it's gonna kill the
franchise this is not I don't want to
kill this franchise and I know that you
love it
I want to let this franchise thrive and
I just feel like your idea is fun but
there's not much thought behind it and I
want to make a great movie that's what I
want to do more than anything
alright time Mon what did I say online
there was some disappointment in a
classroom setting for Mike I think
people wanted more of an adventure story
but once the songs came in really touch
of the movie which yeah and you're out
and the viewers are really desperate to
hear what our debate coach has what
happens when music begins in the middle
of a round okay oh and you would please
vote again option one will be Mike
option two will be Dan but make sure you
vote on Twitter now turn on YouTube vote
on Twitter at Ashton juggies you can
twit at screen junkies vote one for Mike
Carlson two for Dan Merle go vote right
now as we talk go ahead yeah but Mike
let's see your thoughts bass interesting
round and we said we would count some
career
see I'm curious how you roll this go
ahead yeah I think that I'm gonna vote
for Mike in this one the I think Dan
lets the debate be too much about Mike's
and even though he keeps just attacking
it I don't I don't know anything about
what Dan Louise Dan's movies gonna be
about I may not love Mike as a writer
and a director but I only have just met
Mike so I trust that I mean I feel like
there's a more complete movie on Mike's
side than on dance side the songs you
know what you know it's weird I have the
same thing because that last thing dance
it was the airs is fun not you said
yours it's fun but not much thought you
admitted it was fun and he put in talked
about all the characters and here's
where it was other interesting he said
fans of the ride want to see this no one
else wants to see a Botanica movie so I
feel like he had made a good point for
me of that but let's see what the fans
think fans out there I gotta say the
songs did put it up clinched it for me
because I don't remember what your movie
is too much I mean yes it was something
about the crunch in this round quickly
real quick where do I even begin
okay so Mike's pitch sounded kind of
like like the substitute teacher Kim
peels sketch meets like an Adam Sandler
movie which one did you see it's Mike
sorry no click around anybody you want
to see dance I would want to see dance
because Mike's doesn't even sound like a
Botanica smoothie anymore it just kind
of sounds like it's just going off into
this different kind of thing where it
was supposed to be serious that you're
throwing comedy and music music in there
whereas I said sounds like an adventure
you said this is gonna be completely
serious and then every other word that
came out of your mouth was a comedy what
he says what he says
alright Dan what did the audience vote
extraordinarily close once again
because you're giving them a future the
option come on damn it actually is the
exact same breakdown as the last one 51
percent for one of the options 49
percent for the other one I'm just
reloading to see if it reloaded it is
exactly the same result as the last
really it would have one percent to my
one percent to my 49% round one change
at all let me know let me do this do I
have a fan vote of people in the room
who were hired three are dizzle you're
voting and I'm are you're voting for
Mike's movie alright so one for Dan and
three for Mike can I just jump in and
say I thought as much as I used to it as
much as I enjoyed the songs I think Dan
was the clear victor in terms of the
arguments and I was really surprised to
hear I thought that was gonna be
everybody's look yeah hey look that's
what it is I don't know I didn't I I
love the song well here's what's
interesting I mean it's hard to debate a
pitch round is it's a different thing
it's a creative choice so there is some
personal points and I'm I promise again
I'm gonna stick with cuz I'm gonna give
Mike the points I just I don't know yes
there was a little I agree with you the
tone was mixed but then when he ended up
showing the tone and he committed to it
so seriously
they was sort of like the happening for
me
and I still don't remember I was
listening I took notes about the
humanoids it's confused what was
happening so Mike's mics and with with
the round here and the voting poll might
gets that point there we go round one
the vote is now 54 percent for Mike 46
percent for Dan
so it's changing but okay so we'll try
and do a little here and see a little
I'm also gonna mix up the next poll next
time it's gonna be Dan rights gonna be
one yeah and Michael number man so this
would be prepared all right so here we
go
round three now in this in these next
two polls we did try and pick a question
that was more analytical for Dan and
more creative for Mike so you'll see
that in the next year round some
producers choice here we picked
something that felt more to Dan
strengths and then one that's more to
Mike strengths so first up round 3 best
movie trilogy and this time I bet I
think we're back to you Dan right yeah
yes again
very tough let's hear who you're picking
what is your the Rings trilogy lower the
rank Dan I'm sorry I'm Mike what are you
picking Toy Story Toy Story okay great
dan go ahead I think when you're judging
best trilogy it's it's not just three
great movies I think that you're looking
at three movies that tell both an
overarching story and then movies it's
not a trick question go ahead reset no
trilogy I think you're talking about
both three good movies and three movies
that tell a great story across all three
I think that's why for me the Godfather
trilogy was not in part of this
discussion while Godfather Godfather two
of great movies I don't think Godfather
three is a great movie so that's why I
think Lord the Rings because this is a
film trilogy that individually each film
is a satisfying experience each film
tells its own story each film has a
beginning a middle and an end and then
together they tell amongst all three a
very compelling epic story so you can
watch one at a time you can watch them
all together the viewing experience is
just as satisfying either way audiences
love them it wasn't that thing of the
first movie comes out and you're like I
don't know I mean I'll have to see what
the other two were like before I can
really judge this one every movie that
came out people loved as it came out
they weren't saying I have to wait and
see what the next one is and I think
that's why you know port before it for
being able to interconnect all the
stories as well as they did but also
make three compelling satisfying well
made movies on their own elements that's
what makes this the best movie trilogy
for me there's a lot more that I can
talk about and we'll come to it Mike
toys Dan you're gonna be so mad at me by
the end of this round a Lord of the
Rings all Sleepy first of all these
movies are a little sleepy and as far as
we're talking about earlier but like you
can't you don't remember what is what I
think like yeah Lord of the Rings don't
look it is those are good movies I saw
them I liked them but we're talking
about Toy Story these are characters and
situations and scenes and elements even
just icon iconography like pop
culturally like stuff that resonates so
much more I mean when you're when you're
thinking about the Toy Story movies
versus Lord of the Rings like I cannot
remember like which giant CGI battle was
when in which
movie I think I remember thank you we'll
do that later like like when we're
talking about this character is like I
feel like Wallace shot look I love
Wallace Shawn but Wallace Shawn's Rex is
like more memorable than a lot of like
whatever the tenth character in Lord of
the Rings is like much more memorable
and you can know who he is as a
character and is a you know a person is
a little dinosaur than you do like God
sure like Gollum I think like culturally
people know Gollum in a little a Gandalf
but like all the Toy Story characters
are iconic like even the new ones mr.
Pricklepants has like six lines in the
new Toy Story movie but like he's great
Timothy Dalton's mr. Pricklepants maybe
that was a bad choice I just think you
know this is these are a trilogy of
movies that also like do something you
know like they tell they're really sort
of telling one boy's story Andy over the
course of so many so many movies and
like each movie deals with like a
totally different theme and blah blah
blah anyway these are better these are
better than the load of things movies
yeah I disagree wholeheartedly
I think Toy Story those are three really
good movies I think that they don't
first of all they're not even gonna be a
trilogy for very much longer we're gonna
have a Toy Story 4 and now you're gonna
have for Toy Story movies and not three
toy story movies I think though this
this the three first three are Andy's
story so that is a trilogy of Toy Story
movies that is and Easter now they have
a female who's playing with them and
we're gonna get it from a perspective of
God but then are we getting three more
two more of the feed I have to say I
think that they're just pumping out Toy
Story movies like there was no real plan
they're just like hey what do you buzz
they're doing well we're gonna make
three movies secondly I don't these
these movies have good moments they have
touching moments in them but I feel like
they kind of work on a structure which
is the toys are happy they're in a home
they get lost or stolen they learn a
lesson they go back home and that's what
happen the first once what happens in
the second one's having to the third one
I think that stinky peed and lots of
huggin bear are kind of the same villain
it's a guy Oh people used to play with
me and now I'm angry nobody gets to play
with any of you and I think that's kind
of repeated a bit I think that you have
you know funny characters and they're
fun movies but as a trilogy I don't see
how they they stack up storytelling wise
to legs I don't think the flutterings
movies are
sleepy if the Lord of the Rings movies
were a little sleepy then people
wouldn't go and buy the version that's
three hours longer and say oh I want to
watch that that's the person I want to
watch to like I love these moves from
their interiors I love them so much I
want to see the longer versions of them
if they were sleepy I don't think maybe
you found them boring I think that they
are really interesting really compelling
I think they have great characters I
think Boromir who's only in the first
movie he's way more memorable to me I
know that Rex is a dinosaur to go
Boromir is such a complex character
those characters are so much more
developed than the toys a toy story
they're cute they're fun movies but from
a storytelling standpoint and just from
a craft standpoint I mean those movies
are just like handmade almost I mean
they built these massive sets the
interconnected and they shot them all at
the same time I don't see how it even
compares as a trilogy to Lord of the
Rings like well I mean first of all all
these movies have like similar things
like there are so many like bunch of
guys in a big field with a good versus
another bunch of guys in a big field
that happens a lot like you can come you
can die now movies there's a big fight
in the second one - yeah they're not
what are they in stones are they on
stone I've seen like the Toy Story movie
I honestly have seen Toy Story 3 like
once and I know so much more about it
than I do these movie but like this good
simplifying Toy Story is like these
movies are all about the same thing it's
not true like number one is about
jealousy number two is like abandonment
and searching for a place to belong
number three has got two overtones of
like sexual frustration and becoming an
adult and ultimately like confronting
your own death which is like the
heaviest scene I've ever seen in a movie
this is a kids movie this is supposed to
be a Disney product but all the
characters clutch each other's hands and
are prepared to die this is insane
this blew my mind in the movie theater
like how could they do this and I'm like
does this simplify these movies is like
products and they're very similar it's
crazy like yes the Lord of the Rings are
like duo but like look what you can see
you know what Pizza Planet looks like I
know what the Pizza Planet logo looks
like that I know what then is terras
looks like yeah but you're one of the
only people I feel like that is not a
ball that's that's not true let's poll
people if they know Pizza Planet more
than
whatever the word you just said menace
terrace menace terrace okay and as far
as like it being innovator like
handcrafted sets in Toy Story one is a
brilliant piece of filmmaking that
starts everything for that like for
computer-generated movies this is the
first one it's talking about like how
well-crafted and acting like this stuff
is just something that a computer [ __ ]
out is crazy like that first movie is so
innovative and it deserves so much
credit we just take it for granted now
that this is even an art form and this
these movie started it well okay so we
were talking innovation yes difference
okay Toy Story was a different kind of
animated kids movie I will grant you
that but it wasn't animated kids we've
been making animated kids movies for
years they've been succeed for decades
animated kids movies have been
succeeding Lord of the Rings was an
unfilmable book and a genre that if you
attempted it was the box-office poison
it was pegged as a disaster nobody
thought it would work nobody thought it
would be any good
the cast was you know familiar faces but
it didn't have an a-list cast this thing
had everything going to guess it had to
director Peter Jackson who never made
anything even close to the scale you had
all these things working against it and
yet somehow because they put this thing
together so well because they paid off
the characters they knew what parts of
the book to change how many times have
you seen an adaptation of a book or
anything as one of those Lord of the
Rings that the fans of that thing like
yeah I'm ok with that like they made an
unfilmable book into a movie that even
the fans of the book loved which is so
incredibly difficult and again each
movie on its own beginning middle end
tells a story in service to this bigger
more epic story these movies got more
successful as they went along they found
a bigger audience as they went along
they mainstream the genre that was
booked the book ended for nerds that
nobody really cared about toy stories
they're cute kids movies but they've
been making those three years Lord of
the Rings advanced that genre and really
made it of course to be reckoned with at
the box-office critically commercially
in a way that no other movie has ever
been able to do up to that point
well you're selling toy story short by
just calling it a kids movie I mean
that's crazy these movies go deep and
these movies speak to things and they're
yeah they appear simple and also like
like yeah and you're also selling it
short that like computer jet although
they did animated kids will they make
movies before that this is a different
type of movie if you
look at those animatics and stuff no one
knew this was gonna work I mean this is
similar to like when you read about Walt
Disney like not knowing if like sound
would work with animation and everyone
was mine it was blown when it happened
like if you look at those animatics and
and when they were putting this movie
together it's crazy like his first
innovation or it's a it's a tap
monumental task to make it even work
this is Toy Story as well and yet like
these movies are good look I'm what I'm
saying sleepy I just means that these
movies are very long and for one starts
to I don't know where one starts on one
ends like this is almost like which
three movies that are one long 12 hour
movie Toy Story has distinct chapters
and and tones and themes and I believe
that because of that it's the better
overall pit when you look at all three
things separately and I think that'll
thoughts go whenever Dan goes yeah I
don't think it's like one long when they
think that's why this works as a trilogy
I think that the first love the Rings
movie I think that Fellowship is about
making the choice and fate and and what
you know rejecting this call and
realizing that you know you have to be
this hero I think that too is about
commitment and friendship and then I
think that three again three is just
about it's almost about family and it's
about this idea of despite the fact that
you're spread out all over the planet
essentially that you can succeed with
the help of your friends and that's the
only thing that's gonna get away from
you and this is this idea of this huge
monolith that's essentially brought down
by this group of people you know a dozen
people and they bring down this massive
thing that nobody thought that they can
beat so I think to say it's one long
movie that's not sure I think each of
you addresses specific themes and I
don't think that they run together I
think that they all have their own thing
to say in service of the larger story
final thoughts Mike and I the third
movie the third movie starts out with a
scene of fantasy essentially a fantasy
scene with all the characters are being
like played with by a by Andy to dismiss
this is a sticks on micro this dismiss
the movies as childish like I am Andy we
as nerd people are Andy these are movies
this kid was the same age as I was about
like just roughly like they played with
the numbers so I was a little older
the time 3 came out but like to see
movies about how kids play and how the
toys coming to life would reflect your
adolescence is an incredibly powerful
and incredibly moving thing and that is
why these movies resonate so much and
end up resonating better I think than
Lord of the Rings which are good look
I'm poking fun these are good movies but
Toy Story resonates with the culture and
it resonates with me more and I would
argue that Wolverines does the same
would you like one last line Mike to
infinity and beyond alright now again
this time vote for one for Dan and lower
the Rings or go to Twitter at screen
duckies and vote 2 for Mike Carlson and
Toy Story okay boating started please go
vote and B vote responsibly one Wow lots
of trilogies as happens every single
time we argue about trilogies people got
into it in the comments about the
Cornetto trilogy does the Cornetto
trilogy count as a trilogy are those
totally disconnected Phillips took up a
lot of the comments also Back to the
Future suggested a lot Star Wars the
original Star Wars trilogy Dark Knight
and then an interesting one that came up
a lot Captain America now people are
considering its own sort of three movie
trilogy it's I think that's another
that's three movies but yes that MCU
feels like the franchise as opposed to
that being a trilogy usage also there
was discussion about movies that have
gone on to make more films can you just
consider the first three a trilogy so
like would Indiana Jones have counted if
we just said the first three debatable
right side debate they didn't that was
what was happening in the in the
comments also Minas Tirith is the
capital of Gondor everybody come on you
know I didn't know that all right Mike
let's go to you based on the debates I
think that excuse me dad actually did
bring up the point about it not being a
true trilogy that they're gonna make
more and that and I think there needs to
be some I don't I don't know Dan does a
much better job of explaining why it's a
trilogy by the story arc through all
movies is really good and each
individual movie has its own things but
that the
but in terms of take it as a trilogy I'm
going with Dan because I think that
there's no real explanation as to why
Toy Story is a trilogy other than there
are just three of them great well go
quickly the fans as we get a little bit
more voting go ahead let's go Dakota
what do you think our sorry whoever is
Mike sir well I think Dan won ultimately
while Toy Story is a great franchise as
well as Lord of the Rings I also think
Toy Story has an overall satisfying
ending as a trilogy
I see Lord of the Rings bringing people
together more as where as Christmas time
comes around you hear more people go
let's watch Lord of the Rings or let's
watch you know something else I don't
hear I don't hear a Toy Story that much
I mean personally I've seen Lord the
Rings trilogy every holiday I hear a
bunch of other people talking about it
and as well as the books and I hear how
swans an impossible black all right cool
mr what do you think Greg quick-quick
Toy Story movies they're like my
favorite movies I was very excited when
Mike chose them as his argument but I
was very letdown yeah I think Tim killed
that one Lord of the Rings is known as
one of the best trailers used for a
reason and he proved it so there's an
agreement or yeah Dan a very ending
author of it being separate orc boom
look deadline what is the votes Paul
saying so Dan is option one this time
correct used option yes yes 52% for Dan
and option 1 it just it just changed 53%
to 47% for option that's pretty
unanimous and I don't disagree I think
Mikey you also just started to a little
poorly you blah blah blah that'll go in
there beginning you came around strong
at the end but Dan was definitely
hitting the hardest depth and complexity
I thought that was a really good yeah I
did think you explained the there's
standalone but then they tell the case
of story it was it was good right there
we go I did not have time to watch all
through movies right fair enough
round for now this is a more creative
pitched and a little bit of dimension is
more analytical now Mike you get a
little bit of Angier because this is
another pitch question you are a
commercial actor see you on TV all the
time I am yes next exams and
yeah I'm a man about town and kollywood
I had a lot of different things so Camus
guy your monitor next yeah well in this
question you're gonna go first pitch a
movie based on a commercial so you must
pitch a commercial that we've heard of
and pitch us the movie version of that
said commercial Mike let's hear it okay
everyone familiar hopefully with the
tootsie roll the classic tootsie roll
pop or Marshall playing them are we
allowed to leave okay there's the
picture okay so the basic setup is this
this naked child goes and talks to
different animals ask them the child
will not be naked in the movie just cuz
I have the MPAA I wouldn't I would like
it to be no not like Joker book he goes
to different animals and asks how many
licks does it take to the center of a
tootsie roll at the end of the the story
the owl takes it and he goes one two
three then he bites it like a dick
the owl yeah I love hands him back the
stick and then the kids just confused
and that's the end of the commercial and
it's one unlike the but it's like
probably most famous commercial ever so
I'm taking that and I'm expanding on it
so look we have a young boy at home
let's think of it like a Tom Holland
type he might be too expensive to get
now all right he is having trouble at
home we know the parents fighting blah
blah blah setup and classic set up and
he goes to sleep one night and he is
transported to tutsi land and touching
Lane is a magical place that is filled
with all of the different candy that the
tootsie roll company makes so there are
characters you know interpoma morphic
versions of the characters and then
their lands based on the curse so he
meets a character very first he's
excited you know he's he's candy
everywhere he's eating it's a little
Willy Wonka style then he meets
character named sugar daddy okay and
sugar daddy looks like a the candy sugar
daddy and he tells him look if you want
to get out of here you need to go find
the answer to the question that is
plagued our our our world for a long
time how many licks does it take to get
to the center of a Tootsie Roll pop and
he sets out on an epic quest
an epic quest not unlike the epic quest
in the great movie Lord of the Rings
which is a fantastic movie and I think
is a template that we should look toward
this movie because these movies are
these movies resonated great trilogy the
great trilogy of films probably I would
say even maybe the best um now so he and
he goes to different lands he goes to
different places he you know he meets
mr. cow and Charleston chul and he meets
mr. Fox in double bubble Springs you
know they're a teat they're attacked by
the evil Razzles candy okay this is a
fun adventure and ultimately at the end
we get to Mister all which is in the
Andes Chocolate Mountains and there are
thin mints also the evil thin mint bad
guys hanging around and mr. OWL does a
very similar thing to the commercial he
asked mr. L how many licks does it take
to get to the center of a Tootsie Roll
pop yulux
bites throws it away and the kid is
confused and then he realizes what this
whole thing has been about is a search
for God and essentially what has
happened is he looked to God he said
where are the answers why are we here
God licked the sucker three times Bennet
threw it away and it's way too late the
answer is we don't know we'll never know
he learns an important lesson about life
he's transported back to his home life
and everything is fine Wow
deep alright Dan let's hear more let's
see what commercial you picked I did I
picked convert these I picked something
that fascinates me something that I
would actually go to a theater to learn
a little bit more about and and I picked
commercial mascots that are very
confusing to me and that I don't really
understand why they exist and that is
the Charmin Bears I don't know why bears
are toilet-paper mascots but they look
you know they look cute they look fun so
I figured let's let's build a movie
around them and the Charmin bears play
themselves in this movie this is a this
is a live action animation hybrid movie
the sugar bears are playing themselves
they're high on life they are look at
them they're popular CG depends on the
budget hug animation is very expensive
so we'll see what kind of budget we can
get for this but we'll see it's kind of
it's got to be mixed as you'll see here
in a second I'm sorry but the Charmin
bears playing themselves they're high on
life they're cartoon mascots until
they're replaced they're replaced by the
Charmin miniature horses because what's
cuter than bears horses and they make
just as
census bears so why not just make
Charmin miniature horses so the Bears
are exiled and they have to go live in
the land of former mascots now this is
kind of similar to Mike in that we meet
a cast of characters in the land of
former mascots I'm talking grimace from
McDonald's well I'm talking a little
penny from the Nike ads the other two
Cinnamon Toast Crunch chefs that
disappeared Max Headroom so many of
former commercial people and basically
they're all out of work this is kind of
like a wreckit-ralph type situation
where they're basically in a no-man's
land
so the Charmin Bears have to learn like
to literally actually [ __ ] in the woods
which is again this thing that bears do
that they've never had to do until they
uncover a plan by the noid now I don't
know if you know the noid but the noid
was the Dominos mascot for many many
years it was always up to no good the
noid has decided that T is going to
round up all of the current commercial
mascots and send them to space so that
he will be the only mascot and he will
do all the advertising he's disgruntled
so the Charmin bears saved the current
day mascots they team up with the four
mascots that nobody wants they rescue
everybody everyone is happy and they
ignite this whole retro thing so now all
the old mascots they're popular again
because that's what's that's what's hip
now is you take some from the 80s and
the 90s you rediscover them now they're
cool the Charmin bears are back on top
everybody's happy it's a kids movie it's
fun it's a quick 85 90 minutes you're
gonna go in you're gonna smile you're
gonna have a little bit of nostalgia and
you're gonna come out having had a fun
adventure and you know whether you're
thirty or ten there's gonna be something
for everybody it's a family film all
right we'll fight it out all right I'd
like to do a quick what I assume in a
quick improvisation about what will
happen at the McDonald company when they
get the call to license their IP to this
movie hello
oh you'd like to use grima's for a movie
yeah Oh a movie about [ __ ] bears
shitless [ __ ] you mean a [ __ ] bears from
the commercials uh no no thank you we
don't we would agree mrs. to beloved of
an IP and we would not want him to be in
a movie up with [ __ ] bears so sorry hang
up
never gonna happen folks this thing is -
look this thing is crude first of all
this is this is bizarre by the way the
he's right this all mines bizarre this
is bizarre okay these are bears first of
all did you see the picture we put the
picture back up where the young bear has
just toilet paper on his butt it's crazy
like a strong one not the straw it's the
ultra strong strong strong think about
Sherman is it's both soft and ultra
strong it I did some research and the
thing is Dan just said that thank you
for the segue there was a lawsuit about
how this Sherman is not as strong as it
claims to be bottom PNG toilet paper ads
declared misleading okay so you're gonna
have a lot of controversy to surrounds
this movie initially because maybe this
toilet paper isn't as good as they say
it is that's at least what these people
are alleging and in look like this is
mine is a very straightforward movie
with candy not [ __ ] like the candy is
better than [ __ ] that's a math problem
fine first of all I'd like to say that
mike has not attacked the substance of
my movie whatsoever it's everything
about lawsuits I don't care first of all
have you seen the billboards around town
there's a movie coming up that's
literally got a smiling [ __ ] on it 20
feet long and 12 feet wide this is a new
world that we're living in standards are
outdated number one you some very out of
touch with what families will go to
nowadays we don't know
we're going to a [ __ ] movie who cares
okay
Grima liked your hold by argument is
that Oh McDonald's don't like to use
grimace I'd find there's like twenty
five thousand you snug a file put the
Snuggle Bear in there if we can't use
grimace that's all with this snuggle
bear' work either you let me do a talk
about everybody you smell bad [ __ ] bear
the [ __ ] bear movie no we can't do that
let me talk about your movie because
just from a storytelling perspective yes
your movie is about a kid who goes to
some a very boring place and learns
nothing and goes home boring police
aren't gonna like him learning he learns
about God he learns about the exist
nature of existence and he goes to a
place with his candy it's every kid
loves candy yeah kids love sugar daddies
and whatever 40 year old Canyon you just
pitched in that African that commercial
was old when I was a kid and that was
1989 is here that commercials persevered
for a reason because the IP and that
commercial have been resonating with
people kids of generations for years the
Charmin Bears let's I'm to be honest
we're gonna look back at the single
there was [ __ ] bears on TV using the
term [ __ ] bears you're using your stodgy
standards to deflect the fact that your
movie isn't really about anything people
are gonna go to this animated movie and
feel hoodwinked you get this message
about God and then the kid goes home and
you doesn't even get what he goes there
for like as a storyteller that's just
bad storytelling and I'm gonna be angry
I was angry when you know white and it
didn't have a story I don't want a movie
that has no story that's like oh God and
you know where's my story don't you
different animals and then he learns
about the nature of existence is a
lesson like whether I'm being glib or
not that's a lesson it's a boring lesson
it's a depressing lesson and it's not
one that I want to go seeing it's not
one that the families of America want to
go see I am pitching a fun nostalgic
romp I'm sorry that it doesn't meet your
standards but it's not standards of
America [ __ ] is being advertised right
now as family movies and this will fly
with today's family get what the times
you as your final I'm gonna do with my
final I'm gonna do a quick improvisation
I'm going to talk to a hypothetical
child hey buddy there's two movies
playing on the theater right now one is
about a kid who goes to a magical land
of candy and eats candy and he meets
different kind of an
they talk and they have an adventure and
it's really exciting or there's a movie
where the that the point of the
characters is to go figure out how to
take a big dump in the woods yeah
there's bears but like the whole thing
it's like you're gonna see like [ __ ]
come out of there bare butts like you're
saying that I'm not what we look if that
if there's no [ __ ] coming out of a bears
but what is the payoff what's the point
of doing the Sherman we're moving I
don't think you did say there would be
[ __ ] come on yeah but how do we show oh
we're gonna just show him like the birds
will flutter away out of the forest
we're gonna be suggestive here we gotta
show it baby if we're doing bastoy
double-layered kids movies they're out
there the adults are gonna know what's
going on I don't know laughs the whole
point of the movie is that that I'm
figuring out how to take a dump in a
wood that was one aspect in the movie
now the whole point of the movie all
right oh the noid isn't it
I'm in annoyed alright this time vote
number one for Mike Carlson and the
Tootsie Roll pop at leading to the know
exists that no existence of a god or
whatever how we exactly
and then Dan's I did a classic Trump
movie Sherman bears meeting all the
other mixed up washed up and they save
the all the the brands they do okay
number two for Dan one for Mike and
tootsie roll pop two for Dan Sherman
bells go vote that's true Nicky's our
Twitter lon what do they say online very
fitting number two for Dan it was so
much fun to get to watch a debate coach
write down candy is better than [ __ ] was
like that because Dan's emoji movie
point was amazing and I was leading and
then that was just that's a that's a
reading upon devastating blow there were
a lot of other commercials people
mentioned Old Spice came up a ton the
Geico gecko came up the bunch and then I
thought someone that's or Kendall
Jenner's solving the world's problems by
passing
[Music]
all right Mike what do you think based
on those arguments
the Nostalgia issue both sides getting
nostalgia in other side wins this tells
you the story issue goes to Mike because
I like the idea that the journey is the
adventure itself and that man has to be
an answer at the end I don't know
anything about the lesson or what's
learned in Dan's movie also the issue of
IP is probably a relevant issue i the
ostensibly the could see people would
own everything that's in their movie
they haven't had this IP problem
Dan's movie hundreds of companies would
be called and I think that many of them
would say now so I would go with Mike
Wow it's just my conjecture your honor
let's go to the fans real quick let's go
around which movie would you guys want
to see let's right well I just want to
curious raise your hands Mike's Tootsie
Roll pop movie only Ammar okay and all
three of you when I'm going to see the
Charmin Bears movie I don't want to see
either all right got it to the fan
alright any quick any quick hot all
right good what is it what's the pulse a
line option one was can we say it one
more time people are having a little
trouble my ring was optional around
around so option one is my and Dan was
option number two right now Sherman
right now option two is leaving only
slightly Dan's leading 51%
- Mike Carlson's 49% the toughness
Wadena tongue no look I think I actually
like Mike's points there they were they
are valid but I don't there was just a
such a strength and I thought Mike was
crushing it and then when Dan did that
counter punch it sort of he never really
got back up Mike got a little lost and
trumped himself about which I didn't
know if it was very us fair so I got and
the fact that Dan was able to call him
out for it I do to say that Dan defended
himself better I'm gonna give Dan that
point as well Dan's on the board with
three two one all right round five this
is the most requested fan question I'm
excited for this is gonna be an epic
brawl let's see how that says this came
of so many fans but rematch for episode
best Spielberg movie but really the
matter of the fact is ET vs. Jaws we
know you both are very passionate about
these films Mike you just went very deep
in the lore of ET so I assume you'll be
picking ET you're correct and Dan will
be picking jaws yes indeed great okay
and then who is four oh it's oh I have
Mike here first
Mike so again this is about ET versus
John which is the better film let's hear
it out Mike alright this I'm gonna tell
a quick anecdote okay before you do that
yes there was a fan pull that Mike and
Dan do not know about no great we asked
the fans at home would you like to see
this as a regular fight or would you
like to see this be a trick question I
don't know the answer I bet I know so
lon this is potentially a trick question
look so I wanted to see this straight
but look I thought in order that the
fans really seemed on it there but we
put it off there do you want to see this
in an epic fair fight or do you want the
trick question lon what were the results
by 66 percent I want to see a trick
question well this is that a trick
question
Miami player this game no notes for jaws
vs et on my paper because I expected
this might I mean I gotta come come on
so to clear Mike in because he doesn't
watch the show they must now fight for
the other film that they're not as
passionate about but you must sell it
like you are okay and look this is not
that hard cuz you both pick pretty great
films sure so but you're gonna have to
go against and tell me why the other one
is the better film that means Mike
you'll be defending jaws and Dan
you'll be fent defending et alright Mike
your first alright yeah really go
off-book I love this is really about the
debate off-the-cuff debate all right
jaws does a lot with a little this is a
movie that is about you know fighting a
shark it's about you know a horrible
thing that's happening on a mini island
but really what this movie is about is
three dudes hanging out and I say that
in a you know a flippant way but that is
what it is this is a hangout movie this
is a movie that digs into three
characters better than any movie ever
which is why this thing still lasts to
this day I mean the shark and that stuff
is all very iconic but we're dealing
with a movie that makes you know these
three men we know their relationships
it's almost like you're hanging out it's
like one of the great hangout films
really of all time these are three fully
realized characters these in a situation
they're in close quarters where they get
to the bottom I mean the scene where
they're with this show in the scars I
mean that's something that like everyone
quotes everyone knows that scene whether
you've seen it once whether you've seen
it ten times on top of all of this then
you've got just an incredibly well-made
well executed movie about trying to kill
a giant shark which is just literally
icing on the cake of an already amazing
movie about these amazing characters
jaws is the best speech steven spielberg
movie and it is the one that i think
people remember the most moments from
dan ET i think that jaws is extremely
impressive for Steven Spielberg's first
movie I think it's fairly well
publicized that Spielberg didn't know
what the hell he was doing when he made
jaws he didn't get to make the film that
he wanted and I think that the film
suffers because of that I don't
think it's executed to its fullest he's
kind of he's still doing his omage he's
still doing this kind of film school
tricks he's using the Alfred Hitchcock
camera angles he's kind of taking from
that 70s Verte style of you know
naturalism it's it's I could see the
filmmaker the Steven Spielberg is going
to be when I watch jaws but I also see
the filmmakers that Steven Spielberg was
borrowing from in that movie
et almost a decade later about seven
years later he's come into his own and I
think this is a movie that very easily
could have strayed into just
unbelievably sappy territory and you
take this this this puppet I mean that's
what heat is it's a puppet and through
the the story the stories is amazingly
well-written script by Melissa Mathison
and I think that what he did was he took
this kind of this this concept of boy
and his dog type story that could have
just been a retread and just through the
way that he shot it through the with the
John Williams score the way that he cast
Eliot Henry Thomas one of the best child
performances in any movie ever I think
in Jaws you have three great proven
actors in this one you have a lot of
unknowns that deliver amazing
performances and I think that this is
kind of the most pure Spielberg because
he shoots this film and you see this
film through a child's eyes a lot of it
is shot from the perspective from the
height of a child it's so much of it is
just a pure uncut Spielberg that it's
kind of his signature film that you see
this is how Steven Spielberg sees the
world it's a hopeful place it's a place
where a friend will come down from outer
space and befriend you and even though
the government's gonna try to get you he
revives things he brings life I think
that jaws is a really impressive movie
but I don't really see it as much of a
Spielberg movie as ET is I think et is
really him using every tool at his
disposal to just craft an incredibly
touching film that still I I disagree
that going across the moon is just as
iconic as the the fin in the water I
think that these are both movies that
are held in regard I don't think the
jaws has the advantage there oh okay
when you're talking about like a truck
like yeah okay this is this movie Jaws
famously like there are prot like they
have problems on the set that do the
shower
not working if you've ever seen the
Universal Studios towards they play it
every time and you're like the Sharks
not working I mean it's a triumph coming
out of chaos like I don't think you can
knock it for for whatever some problems
I think that in spite of all this it
deserves to be heralded more because of
all the problems that were going on on
set and because this is Steven
Spielberg's first thing I think that
like you needs it like it's it's
incredible that he made this and really
stands up still is the best of his
movies and like yeah we're talking about
a puppet like not like a cute puppet is
one thing but to make a giant
essentially puppet robot whatever you
want to call it still make it menacing
still make it look like it's scary be
able to take because the technology was
limited that time we're talking about a
big robot pup like a big robot shark
that's sunk to the bottom of the ocean
like to be able to take that and still
make it and seem sinister and pop out of
the water when when defend the famous
scene where Roy Scheider is on the boat
and he sticks his head like that's great
like that's an incredible triumph to
make something that big a practical
effect to actually make people believe
it's actually make people this is a
movie that people were scared to go in
the water that's literally like people
around that time there was reports of
like beaches people were not going they
were so afraid of what was going on that
is how much this movie resonated and
it's still how much this movie resonates
if you want to go pump it for puppet
will go puppet for putz bring it on baby
I think that jaws the more you see that
the faker it looks I actually think that
that shot where it comes up out of the
water the first time I think it looks
very fake it kind of comes up and does
this like a little person hobbling up to
the a little shitty as personality the
way that they designed et like et was so
good that they went back and tried to
modernize et and replace it with CGI and
people said like I don't like that the
puppet was better that looked better
that looked more real that looked more
realistic that looked more authentic I
think that jaws is the less you see of
jaws the more scary it is and the more
you see of it the less scary it is
because they just didn't have the
technology to do jaws as realistically
as they could have I think again with et
you and beauty shot is it's easy to prey
on people's terror of the unknown
because that when people were afraid to
go to the water that's what Steven
Spielberg is preying on in that movie
it's the unknown the the beast lurking
under you in the ocean like that is a
very primal terror and it's very easy to
I think it's far more difficult to touch
people in a genuine way without coming
off as sappy without seeming overly
sentimental and that's what I mean et
was a phenomenon and it was on a scale
because it touched people and I think
that's much more difficult to do than
say there's a boogeyman under your bed
and you should be scared I think it
seems a much more delicate balancing act
than just hey be scared of this weird
thing that's under the water well as far
as here's that's yeah it's it's look et
look believe it or not I like et okay
but this is a movie that I think when
you're when you're looking at as a whole
is et you remember obviously the moments
the finger you remember the thing I
think that the in-between parts and jaws
are the stuff that you remember that
make you love this movie more I think
there's a lot of stuff in an ET that are
in between stuff some of the scary
government stuff that are a lot less
watchable when you go back and you go oh
my god this is really like terrifying
and like yes it makes a point but it is
not something that sits with you I think
that yeah you see the score the score
and everything like like you remember
that stuff but as far as jaws I think
that it's it almost the shark being
there it almost doesn't matter it's it's
just does such a good job of fleshing
people out and showing you relationships
like the kid the kid is great in eating
the kids do Berryman penis breath all
that stuff is good but unfortunately
like the kids aren't fleshed out
characters they remind you they're more
sort of analogues for yourself for
yourself as a child I think these are
going to see jaws you're seeing three
characters that you'll find yourself in
pieces of each of them but they're full
three 3d realized characters well as was
brought up in the earlier discussion I
think to finding analogs of yourself as
a child can be varied found that with
Toy Story I think that's a very
meaningful thing for a lot of viewers
and I think that you know the kids I
think do have their own personality I
think that Elliott in particular is a
very well drawn character this kind of
need for an attachment that he's missing
from his absent father they don't have
to spell that storyline out Dee Wallace
is great as Elliott's mom she doesn't
get a lot of screen time but you know
who that character is the worry when
she's waiting for them to come home that
the concern that she shows for their
kids I I wouldn't discount them just
because they're kids I think each of
those kids does have their own unique
character and
I love the characters in Jaws I think
that they are great but there is a
certain amount of time where you're
waiting for the shark to show up there's
a certain amount of time device climbing
I would alright that's almost the best
time in a movie and that is hard to do
in a movie that is about a shark is to
make the best times in the movie the
three people talking and sitting and
making you feel the moon as you were
saying in rear window the mood I
remember you can watch in that movie or
on the boat with them your drink you
like you feel a little drunk you feel
you're giggling with everyone like
that's the stuff that's the good stuff
baby but I think it's easy to put three
great actors in a room and put a camera
on them and just shoot them acting well
and I think that the balancing act with
et as far as the human characters and
also this again like like jaws is in
effect but it was used here and there et
is in effect that if it doesn't work the
whole movie collapses and the fact that
Spielberg was able to okay I'm gonna do
the cinematic elements with the humans
I'm gonna do the technical elements with
the special effects with et with the
puppetry with the character and to meld
those so perfectly into a movie that
turned out so well I think that jaws is
like it's a very distinct difference
it's like oh this the shark part and
this is the human part I think that et
is one kind of great masterpiece meld
painting all melded in the one and jaws
has good parts but I think the whole one
et is you're getting 80 though and ET
like like obviously whoever whoever
crafted ET did a good job but that's a
lot easier to pull off I mean making
just a little it's essentially a suit it
is making a cool suit that like has big
eyes and is cute like that is a lot
easier to do and it makes somebody much
more sympathetic I mean it's like making
making a character there is of course
you know you can make a bad character
but it's it's taking something and it's
a lot easier than making a giant shark
and making a boat movie
I disagree at the shark you look up what
a shark looks like in a boob in a book
and mold of giant shark that's how they
make the shark in Jaws et was like how
do we make this thing like et is like
this far away from looking disgusting he
does but no he's adorable but he's
disgusting he's not disgusting he's
still an alien it I disagree completely
like ETS it's a far more difficult
design to get right then ash it's a big
shark it's it's this picture but big I'm
sure that's probably what he told it
make make make that for me but big and
it sharks are in the water you know what
a shark looks like you know what a shark
does eat
as a characters not just in the fact
he's a character the shark isn't a
character the shark is as famous as ice
maybe was like oh these two the
MacGuffin of the movie et is a critical
character in the movie but you take a
cute puppet and you put a wig on him
versus you took like a 500 pound piece
of metal and dump it in the water and
make people believe it but people know
that sharks in the water and they know
what a shark looks like right I'm just
saying that if we're talking about doing
something that was extraordinary for the
time jaws is a little bit in my mind
yeah both good complicated puppets all
right final thoughts here why again some
here we're going to you first Mike why
is jaws the better film than ET Jaws
from all the elements and all the scenes
and like we didn't even talk about
school were like like jaws donna.donna I
mean that I think is probably the most
famous film score of all time and I
think that you have to give a lot of
credit to the movie for that ayiti I
think people know as well but like jaws
like people do that all the time and
it's because of the movie it's because
of how much that movie resonates et is a
great movie but I think they ultimately
people remember just the cuteness of the
puppet and these big moments in it
versus the whole thing I think jaws when
you're thinking about it the whole
journey is just as important with jaws
more so than ET and I think the DC is a
far more well-rounded movie I think that
jaws is a technically impressive movie
that has some really good scenes because
you had a great cast of actors I think
what et with Steven Spielberg did with a
Det is paint a much more complete
picture of this family which is in
crisis and again he conveys this very
effectively without having to go into a
big family dramatic element and that
brings in this Martian and and again I
think the most impressive thing is like
it's such a played out story a boy and
his dog I mean they've been making that
since Old Yeller and to make it so fresh
and and to balance definitely I mean
yeah I'm score for score I would put et
against jaws any day of the week they
both had cultural relevance so I think
that's a watch to really when it comes
down to me is what is Steven Spielberg's
better what shows meets craftsman ship
more to me jaws or et and for me et just
to the sheer range
he was able to do and again to to tell
this child's story through the eyes of a
child and to put the audience in that
same mindset and and and and touch them
in a ways it's much harder than scaring
them and that's what jaws does and I
think that easy as a much more difficult
job to do I think it doesn't more
effectively and I think that it's a it's
a classic that's touched generations
who first of all I love that we just
twisted you and you both took the film
you loved and argued against it Bravo
very impressive all right coming down to
this as Mike Evans is thoughts lon how's
that how nice in online social media
reacted exactly as you just did at first
people were not loving the trick
question they wanted to hear these guys
argue for the movie they were passionate
about but both fighters really won
everybody over lots of people commenting
about they can't believe that these
weren't the arguments that they had
actually prepared no actually I just
jump into this because it was so
polished one I do have one fat check
Spielberg first film Express and there
was a lot of disagreement online about
whether you would consider et cute or
not and then one of our eight year old
fans tweeted through their mom jaws
would eat et so you consider perhaps all
right fans I'm coming you sing about
let's go to Mike based on those
arguments tell me what happened not
based on the arguments someone could
have brought up Neil Diamond song heart
light that had a huge cultural
significance the so the question for me
is what's the better Spielberg movie I
think that Dan carries us through the
the issue of haking unknown child stars
singing it through the child's eyes that
to me is more quintessential Spielberg
and I think that that doesn't really get
answered very well by Mike everything
from technical story the times between
the action those to me all seem pretty
wash but what is a more quintessential
Spielberg and one with Manon et because
of the child's eyes and done and the
unknown alright and I see I didn't give
the full poll tonight one no let's go
number one for Dan and et and number two
for Mike and jaws so sorry if you've
been voting or have they've already
voted what's the score before I said
there's no sorry so what I said one for
Dan Tim for Mike Mike and one and two
from Mike and jaws they're pairing with
us if you're watching this late we want
to make sure this voting polled matters
all right let's go to the couch who's
got the mic okay I would say Mike wins
because not only is jaws more of a
nostalgia than et it was the first movie
I was shown when I was a kid and I used
to work at Universal and it was the most
asked about ride that's not there and it
was more more voted by employees that it
was their favorite movies and eat eat
when talked about so I would have to go
with that over Dan alright well I think
some personal preferences there based on
the arguments but good noted okay I
think they both did phenomenal but Dan
really had me at the at the end with the
closing and how he talked to us to
burgers and the cinematic and just
everything he said was just spot-on is
perfect so I go for Dan okay Ammar
diesel one adder are you good that's
given some time for the vote
beautiful arguments but I will go with
Dan there's all
dan because what he said how the he was
borrowing but but for ET he wasn't
borrowing and being not she's happy all
right
lon probably not enough time what are
they no I think we need a little here's
what I'm thinking and maybe this old
little if they if they overrule me maybe
we'll see but I think I gotta say I
heard a little bit more from Dan I got a
it just became clear sorry the you just
gave me a little bit more about the the
Spielberg miss the the reasons why the
technically sorry I'm looking for those
looking for a specific point here that
I'm trying to oh it was about the being
it's easier to scare then to just be
cute and go at that point those points
to me we're hit really hard and I never
really heard you take those down Mike
because you could have said well it's
emotional porn easy nostalgia to sort of
you take advantage of those gonna say
and I didn't hear that that back and so
that that was the one that sort of state
manager is like all right that's kind of
fair you're scaring them you're not but
I didn't I I think you could have
knocked et down a little bit for being
leaves it easy to express their problems
I don't don't believe that but that's
sweat so I was a lean towards dam but
let's see what I got it to see we wait
for time to think they're not gonna be
helpful that it's literally 5050 option
wanted to I'm not lying it's alright
here's right down the middle here's what
we'll do let's go to speed round I'm
gonna dock that potentially Dan that's
probably gonna be a Dan point but let's
just see what that says it just went
5149 for Dan okay well there you let me
call it damn good point four to one
Wow Mike I need to earn this in speed
round yes pressure the same speed round
or we do the same question same five
questions you still have a shot here
Mike all right great let's get this P
around before I do that though I want to
say these questions are awesome and they
came from a lot of you so we want to
need more so go to at screen junkies on
Twitter right now there will be a pin
tweet asking for questions for our
celebrity movie fight happening at
screen junkies central next week I'm so
happy to finally announce yes that's
right you've wanted him back forever mr.
Elijah Wood coming back to movie fights
to take on mr. Kevin Smith oh man that's
gonna be insanely epic you were not
gonna miss this fight it's happening as
three Nicky Central's if you got your
tickets get excited you'll be seeing it
among some other three other amazing
shows we're putting together for you and
then yes we will put them on YouTube
later but get excited I'm so happy to
have Elijah back fighting mr. Kevin
Smith and maybe a surprise there so stay
tuned it's gonna be a lot of fun but
that's happening but we need your
questions so go to Twitter at screen
Ducky's now for the pin tweet and start
suggesting your questions for that round
of Elijah vs. Kevin all right
speed round you guys know how this works
right hmm all right we're gonna have
five more questions to do this and get
this going but before before I do that I
do III know we're late but I want to do
is cuz I want to take a moment
especially to thank a fan queued up
music time for a little bit
I was reached out you guys don't know
I'm doing this but I want to do this I
was reached up by a fan I got a quote do
you have that tweet I got from Joe lemon
I'm gonna do a little tribute here
because I didn't know this happened but
I got a tweet from the sky Joe said I
apologize have a story tights lengthy
but I appreciate
here about one of my best friends mr.
cinema OSP was an outstanding family
fights and everything - he's the only
reason I'm a huge movie fan Austin
passed away recently the last
conversation I had with him was about
doing fan fights video because we love
you guys he actually submitted for fan
fights he's the kindest most passionate
Shuman I've ever known and his love
filmmaking was so intelligent he was a
he and I both did submissions his was
better I plan to start a podcast in his
name and I just wanted to thank you guys
I miss him so much and thank you for
listening I was kicking ass I love you
guys and I admire movie fight stage one
every anyway this really touched me and
I went back and I looked up Austin this
guy seems like the nicest most
passionate awesome movie lover I've seen
I'm so sad he had been tweeting me movie
fight questions for that for the Evers
he worked at Walmart at the bargain bin
he was a filmmaker from Indy Fort Wayne
Indiana in Austin I wanted to do this in
honor of our championship fight I wanted
a chips to tribute to you yes in honor
of you as a celebration for thank you
for being a fan I've gone too soon and
I'm so sorry but in honor of that as a
hardcore screen jacket we gotta gotta
honor this guy Austin I'm so so in love
this guy I wanted him to be able to ask
the first bargain bin pic here in honor
of Austin gray number one you're getting
a true on a bargain bin that's legit
from a serious fan and here's how we're
gonna do this here we go
it comes in from Austin on 20 from us
Twitter from a while back here it is
you're gonna name the one you want
scooby Doo
I heard Mike anybody else yeah I like
you're gonna get Scooby Doo and then Dan
you're gonna get a master of disguise I
love it all right there we go you have
this works
no Mike doesn't know this works he'll
have 20 seconds each and then they'll
have 10 second rebuttals and it's time
you ready lon what time begins when you
begin speaking Mike I'm all set
Master disguise ruined Dana Carvey
career it's crazy you could have been a
movie star someone was talented guys
ever like you're not watching that movie
you just kept man going how bad this
isn't how does damage it did scooby-doo
at least have some laughs some IP that
we like James Gunn wrote the screenplay
like you're at least like
this isn't the greatest thing but like
okay Scooby knows bro like okay I
remember that that's vine master of
disguise is so actively bad when you're
watching it alright Dan you have 20
seconds time begins when you begin
speaking yeah Scooby Doo I've seen that
scenes could we do 800 times and I've
seen it better in the cartoon series
good that was a pale imitation of the
cartoon which I like way better master
disguise is something new it's something
different
I love Dana Carvey I like to see the
different sides of Dana Carvey you know
so many different characters in that
movie so many different impressions
I think he's hilarious if you didn't
like the movie that's fine he sells a
great career by the way he's doing
stand-up but you hear him all the time
it's not like this killed his career
Mike he does like corporate gigs and
like far like rich people isn't a great
career like this is the movie that did
it
scooby-doo yeah we've seen a million
times because people like it it's an
enjoyable experience if master disguise
like all rumors is like the turtle
turtle 10 seconds tan nobody's favorite
shaggy is Matthew Lillard I will watch
the scooby-doo cartoon and I will watch
a comedian that I like Dana Carvey the
movie may not be great but he's great in
it and I like him and I think he's funny
and that's the one I want to watch I
wanna watch something fresh Casey Kasem
of courses are shaggy alright just
credit that last point we'll try and get
the fan votes I don't know where some
use the fans in the room sorry guys so
we're running late Mike what do you
think based on that argument I'm going
with a master of disguise because Scooby
got ruined by the movie interesting I
was going the other way but let's hear
what the fans think I surprisingly
actually go with master of disguise I he
sold me on it
Mike sold me master disguise our
scooby-doo anyday based on the arguments
guys based on the arguments I go with
Dan Wow alright interesting and then
Mike went there lon let's get you
involved here can I say my piece and
then you're gonna say yours sure I heard
he did end his career that's true like
it really doesn't mean anything since he
did it stand-up special it's true but
the movie stopped happening so that was
a very noted point for me because I was
a big Dean carving and it's not funny
odd you for trying because you said it
was but that's that's taste whatever but
then you drop the James Gunn thing it's
kind of interesting to look back and
watch because of that is interesting so
I I did get more and then it just fell
no and different is not master in
disguise I just felt like you were
reaching for me
but non I knew you were I know you did I
sit here and say no no you're not for
the points but LAN go ahead
this was it was a little tough but I
think I'm leaning towards Mike as well
be the it ruined Dana Carvey point I
thought it's pretty solid in like yeah
like scooby-doo has been made a bunch of
times but it's cuz audiences enjoy it
it's adorable
I got to go there too so I lawns helping
me over all that it was close in the fan
game I'm giving Mike that point I think
that was a was good there all right
number two mmm guys this comes from Ryan
Porter Wilson on Twitter what movie
character could win the movie fights
championship Randy from scream Arnold
Schwarzenegger is character from Last
Action Hero
okay Last Action Hero Arnold and Randy
from scream Daniel first cuz you went
first 20 seconds when you begin speaking
Randy for screams should have been on
this show I if this movie had been made
20 years ago I would have thought it was
based on one of us he knows every genre
in those action Neela's horror he
screams and yells about the rules of
horror movies that's exactly what we do
on this show about the violation of the
rules like he was made to compete on
movie fights he knows his stuff he knows
the genres he's got the passion and
that's what it takes to win the movie
fights championship Mike he's a famous
actor I've lost to so many famous actors
on the show you know come in here you
guys want to come back he's gonna get a
little bit of a psychological edge
star you're gonna go that's great this
guy is here I can't believe it and he's
gonna like I'm gonna be there I'm gonna
be sweating and eating you can answer
Lera fication
he says hey girl Last Action Hero does I
mean his character in last section here
or who wasn't actor him he's out he is
an actor I think Mike was picking both
he's an that he is Arnold Schwarzenegger
okay it's not playing
in the movie is the police officer yes
to Dan's point Arnold Schwarzenegger
we're only seeing the character that he
plays we're not seeing the actor who
portrays that character so it is a
little I'm just wondering I just wanna
know is for my counter yes he is playing
a famous actor from the world of Last
Action Hero god yes yes yes he's
bringing the famous actor cop I forget
what the name is the guy who plays cop
movie ok ok I'm still really confused
well the movie is a little confusing I
think after of the police officer and
then he plays himself in the movie yes I
was out of the screen in real life no
one with the one in the movie or the one
that jumps out in real life
they're all the same they're all the
same I think it's a little blurred ok
well go ahead use it are you confused
but here's the thing
last section hero is in a different
universe and so if you asked the arms
for standing or sitting here what's the
best Sylvester Stallone movie keepsake
Terminator 2 guess what he's
disqualified and I don't care how famous
you are he has to alternate history
knowledge for 10 seconds Mike he would
get a publicist and they would tell him
like what his famous marvel would be
like why I made two is my favorite two
Marvel movie and any would be like ding
I mean like that we would want him to
come back why would you make a move oh
man that was sorry to help Mike they're
that celebrities do tend to come on the
show and always seem to win so that was
an interesting tactic but I'd and it can
make a good point it was a little
confusing as to which character was
right took go ahead Mike how did he get
he did didn't he did I get my 10 seconds
20s and then you used to talk
coming through the spring disoriented oh
yeah yeah Spaniard ten on Arnold go
ahead Mike I'm voting for Randy because
if I'm the debate judge I'm gonna not be
swayed by the actor famous they're
interesting one yeah the the Arnold
Schwarzenegger last actually I think
really threw me off I I tend to agree
with Dan that that character would be
confused by movie fights so I'm going
with them quick vote hand vocals we're
in a time crunch here vote format for
Mike and uh raise your hand okay Dan
gets the point
alright so do we and is he wet gay no no
he's a night you need the next three to
tie yeah okay here we go okay this is a
rematch from episode 11 so if one does
win this then any wins and that's yeah
rematch from episode 11 where you two
first faced off back in January think of
2015 correct
alright let's settle it once and for all
best Liam Neeson movie and I'm wondering
if I should do it this one even I recall
got tricky because all you gotta give me
a movie and you are correct sir Batman
Begins alright he did not go well we'll
see what happens alright Dan time begins
we begin speaking I'm not getting into
the semantics of it I will say that she
was one of the best movies ever made one
of the best movies of the 20th century
or any century Batman Begins is a really
good Batman movie The Dark Knight is a
better Batman movie and even if you're
gonna go Neeson for Neeson these since
in the first 15 minutes of Batman Begins
in the last 10 he's playing a pre
generic comic villain his performance
and Schindler's List is brilliant one of
the great insights into a damaged psyche
of any character alright what movie do I
want to watch right now Batman Begins
for sure like there's no question that
movie is brilliant it's amazing but like
as far as like what's a better movie I'm
going this movie because it's it's much
more watchable it's got nice in here
great you're understating like he is
very cool he's very evil he really
embodies of a child cool in this whole
plot it starts off a franchise that
acted like the biggest superhero
franchise in the world that's an
incredible movie ten seconds the
question again the semantics the
question wasn't what movie do you wanna
watch right now is best Liam Neeson
movie and Schindler's List is hands-down
a better movie the Batman against Batman
Begins is a good superhero movie
Schindler's List is a powerful brilliant
film ten seconds Mike when you speak or
speak just trying to figure out how
[Laughter]
crazy don't say that it's never over men
is it to say something shocking like
would I be wild man in here or do I just
sort of go on with this all right
five seconds you got to go mm-hmm
Batman Begins is a more important film
than Schindler's List it deals with a
fictional place yes Gotham City but I
think that Batman stopping the gasps oh
my god I said something crazy all the
time we have LAN and Mike what do we
think they're I'm voting for Mike I love
oh you got one from dizzle but Dan gets
the point
[Applause]
man you got it this guy is good one
thing to do and I applaud you for doing
it Mike Wow what do you want to plug I
will plug my personal Twitter fat
Karlsson PHA TCA RLS o n also if you
would be nice I am starting a podcast
with some friends of mine and we're
gonna launch in like a week or two but
if you want to go to the Twitter it's at
podcast the ride yes yes it's so podcast
the ride go follow that and you will get
updated on when we're coming out which
should be soon any day now
we've already recorded the first episode
and I'll tell you this it's about ET
very smart of you very smart marketing
genius Dan Murrow Bravo
the show
Spencer Gilbert we need to clarify here
I have this thing of earnest Tapper from
the MRT the thing is last night our
standing
Mike yeah hang out we didn't hang let's
have them take the chair nonsense just
to clarify for those who are confused
this is a shocker Spencer Gilbert did
earn the I hope I know the code max okay
he won last fighter standing one two
three one last fighter standing and by
the winning the showstopper he is
allowed to challenge whoever wields the
belt any time the champion is live and
on a show which this counts how long is
this episode we go way too long let's
play long Spencer is activating the
showstopper Dan you understand what this
mean I do I got to do the whole thing I
just I was gonna put it that I took a
puppet for puppet on this pay piece of
Arizona favorite thing ever but no let's
do this open it
[Applause]
open the other side that's how useless
in here our confidential questions make
I love is offering his own speeder so
the way this will work first the three
your first five questions your scores
are now reversed super zero zero you
will be asked five speed round questions
there we go
five speed round questions in here
there's a speed round rules you must
answer them in speed round style sweaty
pen whoever wins this speed round earns
the belts are we ready for this let's do
it again you need a new piece of paper
here alright question one
best performance by an actor who only
briefly appears in the movie Alec
Baldwin Glengarry Glen Ross
willem dafoe Boondock Saints okay
boondock all right we got it
dan you went first so you will speak
first time begins when you begin
speaking I'm gonna give them each 25
seconds fair enough Alec Baldwin has one
scene and one seen only in Glengarry
Glen Ross it's not more than five
minutes long and it is the one thing
that people remember from that movie he
put his mark not only on that movie but
on 80s corporate culture that put that
coffee down a coffee's for closers is
one of the most brilliant it's almost
uninterrupted monologue and it is an
amazing piece of acting and to find his
career and to find that movie and I
can't think of it's one of those movie
monologues of all time spencer's time
begins and again speaking 25 seconds
Alec Baldwin is a one speech Pony that
is a good movie even without Alec
Baldwin in it whereas Boondock Saints is
a terrible movie except for Willem
Dafoe's complete over-the-top
performance he's giving you so much that
he elevates what in looking back on is a
piece-of-shit movie
whereas Glengarry Glen Ross is fine but
it it has a great speech in it by Alec
Baldwin but it doesn't make it it's the
best performance by an actor those
briefly in a movie William Willem Dafoe
is as terrible in that movie as that
movie is terrible he adds to the legacy
of that movies terribleness Alec Baldwin
is brilliant if you ask anybody by
Glengarry Glen Ross what do you the
rumor about that movie it's Alec
Baldwin's Glengarry Glen Ross is a play
it's a great monologue it's it's mostly
in the writing it's not in the
performance Willem Dafoe is giving you
something completely original I've seen
80s people like Gordon Gekko before on
film that give you a speech about how
greed no they're kicking your ass Willem
Dafoe something I've never seen on
screen before which is this week all
right that's time I'm gonna incorporate
you my mark I'm sorry Mike what did you
think based on those arguments
a bit unfair to bring up a new argument
when he has no time to response with the
bringing our town speed round word yeah
but I I with the guy you go with your
gut a little bit more on this one yes
and I would say that it I'm gonna go
with the Glengarry Glen Ross because
it's the only part I remember one I had
the exact opposite reaction I love all
sorts of stuff in Glengarry Glen Ross
and Willem Dafoe comes in and salvages
the disaster Boondock Saints so that
surprised me too let's ask the fans
though raise your hands if you if you're
running for Dan and Glen Garry you and
Ross won right who's voting for Spencer
and Boondock Saints Wow I didn't like he
gave up yeah help us but you got me with
the Gordon Gekko thing I've seen it
before you did I haven't seen Willem
Dafoe anywhere best perform an actor
only improves the movie I got to say yes
strangely I'm giving Spencer that first
point so anybody's game here we go
number two stole that one Daniel Daniel
day-lewis or Meryl Streep Daniel
day-lewis Meryl Streep okay I think you
both got fair choice it's both fabulous
actors Meryl Streep for Dan Spencer
you're gonna be first though with Daniel
day-lewis it takes oh wait no sorry
sorry whenever you want I'll start over
all right
it takes a lot to get Daniel day-lewis
to put down his cobbling tools and go on
to a movie set he is the he is the actor
who chooses only the best roles to do
the performances they'll really bring
the best out of him and that deserve the
amount of commitment Meryl Streep's
great she's a working actress she'll do
rom-com she'll do high culture low
culture that's fine Daniel day-lewis you
know every time you see him in a movie
just the fact that he agreed to do it
means that the movie is gonna be
incredible dan I bring up games of new
york to that point number one that is
not an incredible movie number two
Daniel day-lewis is a borderline
psychopath Meryl Streep is an actor she
understands that you don't have to live
the life of the character that you're in
she's a good enough actor that she can
go home and live in an air-conditioning
apartment if she's playing somebody
lived in the 1800s she doesn't go have
to live in a log cabin that she
for herself she can act the part she
doesn't have to delude herself into
thinking that she's the person I'm
portraying Spencer gets 15 seconds
Daniel day-lewis brings a certain amount
of intensity to every role but you just
don't get four male Streep and that's
because he's such a crazy person off
camera who commits and stays in
character that's not a knock against him
that's something to his credit because
it even makes the story around the movie
interesting is that he lived his Lincoln
in a cabin hi Dan
I love that Meryl Streep can make me
believe that she is any character
without having to be any character
without having to be this serious
dramatic character that Daniel day-lewis
is in every single movie Meryl Streep
can be a real person she could be in a
comedy she could be a corporate person
she could be somebody 200 years ago she
could be somebody from the future and
she does every single one of those
convincingly when is she from the future
line and Mike we think Daniel day-lewis
easily I think that excuse me No
Meryl Streep wins Daniel day-lewis loses
he plays a say I agree that he does the
same essentially the same thing every
time yeah I had the same thought I think
I think Dan really wanted in the last
round there where he talked about the
sort of range of Meryl Streep and uh
yeah that was with Spencer and then
Dan's counter really helped me like yeah
I'm gonna give that one to Dan as well
all right we're tied still Wow it's not
helping our two and a half hour show you
ready here we go
next one zero five worst part two to a
great original movie Matrix Reloaded
okay
thinking Iron Man - okay we got Iron Man
- giving you a second there Spencer
you'll be first tell me why Matrix
Reloaded is the worst part - to a great
original whenever you ready the matrix
was a completely original world that
which house keys created and you
couldn't wait to spend more time into it
not in it not only that but it ended on
a cliffhanger where you're wondering oh
what's neo gonna do next against the
machines it turns out he's gonna
pontificate and go up his own butthole
with intro to philosophy lectures there
is no greater gap between the action and
investment level in the characters
between part 1 and part 2 than the
matrix yes you're technically in the
same world but what they do with that
world is so uninteresting and so
cerebral there's nothing for your heart
all right we'll give down a couple extra
seconds there's a Spencer stepped on go
ahead Dan uh if it was between part two
and part three I'd be with you but the
Matrix Reloaded was that was a great
movie that has the best action sequence
of any of the Matrix movies in it that
highway sequence it has some amazing
visual effects that wasn't remain shoot
went off the rails it was in part three
Iron Man 2 took a movie that reinvented
the superhero genre and gave us the
template for every disappointing movie
that would come into the superhero genre
the world-building the laziness you
don't advance the characters you're
bringing in people that shouldn't be in
the movie it is everything that's kind
of a movie shouldn't be and it's even
start the first night what do you repeat
the question
yes worst part - to a great original
movie I would actually want to focus on
how Iron Man 1 is not a great original
movie because it's an existing franchise
and the sin of Iron Man 2 was just to
work in more stuff from the MCU and just
make it a little over stuff Matrix 1 was
brilliant and original and what they did
in part 2 was less original yes it still
had great visual effects
Iron Man 1 is a great movie it birth to
the MCU if that movie hadn't worked the
entire incident worked it gave the
superhero genre a new life and makes ryx
reloaded again technically it's an
advancement over the first one it's not
a huge drop off from the first one 3 is
the one that people hate - is the one in
the middle that still pushes the
envelope I'm gonna give you each 5 more
seconds
one sequence does not a movie make that
movie is a complete disappointment when
it came out today and in the future
three is on par with two five seconds
six seconds for Daniel I came out of
Matrix Reloaded still excited about the
Matrix franchise I came out of Iron Man
2 concerned a now for the future of the
MCU and those movies alright interesting
I was stuck there but helped a little
bit but that's a tough one first let's
raise your hands if you're voting for
Spencer and Matrix Reloaded a great hold
your hand up no one okay you're all
going for Dan okay Mike or LAN anyone
have a different opinion no I I thought
to a niche that one out as well
yeah he helped me in there in the end -
I was a little on the fence but he did
come up with a good closer Mike I was
the same way I think that the arguments
about how it saved all good all right so
we're Dan's up by one here we go number
four
best movie with a title that's six words
or longer I hope you fought this one
answer quickly at dr. Strangelove or how
I learned to stop worrying and love the
bump mm-hmm
yeah you'd argue that exact answer all
right is that fair
was that on our final another six words
six words exactly yes oh my god that's
gonna take a while all right
it's not like we're live yeah I know if
I can come up with one all right okay oh
yeah one yeah Monty Python and the Holy
Grail oh wow you got okay you got it
kind of accept it now and I was about to
change it but since he delivered it
give me a Star Wars Return of the Jedi
[Music]
probably but it's right on the bubble
six okay all right you get it my Python
BFS is only Grail versus Star Wars
Return of the Jedi okay Dan I will take
the best Monty Python movie over maybe
the third or fourth best Star Wars movie
any day of the week I think that money
Casa and the Holy Grail is still revered
as a classic nowadays a classic piece of
absurdist comedy a classic piece of
English comedy
it brought that's what most people know
the Pythons from they came from TV to
that movie return the Jedi is in the
middle of Star Wars films it's not that
great it's overshadowed by Star Wars and
Empire Strikes Back and in some people's
eyes the force awakens the longer it
goes look the further goes down people's
lists Monty Python and the Holy Grail is
a very quotable sketch movie is not a
cohesive film as far as something with a
beginning middle and an end return the
Jedi is a beautifully told conclusion to
a grand arcing story that has the tying
together of all these plot lines the
people been breathlessly awaiting for
decades and it finally brings it brings
you closure whereas Monty Python is a
platformer for money Python deserve
jokes they've done that on television on
Flying Circus they did that in their
future movies it's not unique in their
Panthea history says that the jump for
television to film usually doesn't work
Monty Python reinvented themselves and
in a way reinvented the genre when they
did that that's still a groundbreaking
comedy Return of the Jedi did the Death
Star again and space battles again it's
the Ewoks the worst part of that three
it's a letdown it doesn't even live up
to the first two movies in that Monty
Python all right final seconds for
Spencer 15 if you look at things like
the matrix the third one is the hardest
one to state the fact the fact that's
even a very good movie is impressive
because people as expectations are so
high in the fact that they met them and
at least gave you a satisfying
conclusion is a testament to how good
the third Star Wars is
oh alright one mic cuts I thought I
thought Spencer was doing really well
until at the end there it kind of feels
like he's sort of conceding the point
well listen it was the last one and
that's hard to do so it's pretty good
like I think until then II might add it
but I'm with you but his I was really
impressed with his first one was
surprising me he came out great super
strong so I yeah I'm on hear from the
fans anybody thought so has anyone
voting for Spencer oh yeah all right we
got some votes for Spencer
why tell real quick he at the beginning
the he the way he went in and he
attacked the question I thought it was
was great actually I give it to Dan
because his first was strong and his
second was even stronger Dakota you were
voting for Spencer I was voting for
Spencer because overall I think it
serves a better story look yeah the
first one was dispenser that was I've
got these points town was a lot more
interesting and hard because you pointed
out they've done it on TV the sketch
movie Dan did come back strong with
strongly within any what to eat but
somebody like the he walks I got I'm
giving Spencer that point ok movies Star
Wars episodes this is a controversial
though it's kind of a smashed egg
country you know it's gonna be alright
best sorry best no wait sorry what movie
vehicle do you most want in your garage
my garage
the DeLorean from Back to the Future
Camryn's dad's car in Ferris Bueller's
Day Off alright Dan you're up first
for all the marbles and not only is the
DeLorean a bomb-ass car we're in 2015 so
you know we're past 2015 so we can fly
you don't have to worry about the
plutonium it takes garbage you don't
have to gas it up you can you can by the
way you can time travel not only is it a
great practical vehicle also you can
travel through time which is pretty
amazing I think that Kevin I don't want
a car that I have to like park with
three spaces around because I'm afraid
somebody's gonna ding it and I don't
want that broke-ass car that's at the
end of Ferris Bueller's Day Off which is
how we lost sigh that car by the way
Spencer time begins when you begin
speaking you'd say what car you want to
drive around town you say what car you
want your garage what do you want to
show off what's the coolest car you can
say hey check this out this is not
something you're gonna take on joy rides
it's not something you gotta take around
and [ __ ] up the whole space-time
continuum and have you hooked up with
your own mom this is just a car they
wants it in a garage car a show car
something that you look at and you go
wow that's impressive don't touch
just look it's a garage cocky there okay
but it came out strong Dan you have 15
seconds so you're saying the choice that
I need to make is car I can look and do
nothing with or time machine that can
take me anywhere in the space-time
continuum I'm not gonna mess the garage
time continuum I'm not an idiot I want
it in my garage so I can get in the car
and take it out of the garage which is
why you have a car by the way though by
car to park it in the garage
alright last 15 seconds for Spencer make
them count we're talking show cars and a
Ferrari at least you can get out and
bout on the street and like cruise
around and look for chicks a DeLorean
with a giant pipe hanging on the back
someone's gonna go oh that's a weird
Back to the Future fan also DeLoreans
broke down all the time their crappy
cars that's why they don't make them
anymore the body's made of aluminum
their junk if you've been listening to
be this way things are you're done right
they both went okay
everybody would you like the Scheinman I
didn't know anyone say mater Mike let's
go to you Spencer Spencer wins why
spacetime trip time travel could be
scary you're weird I wrote that two days
time I was like that and it's a more
beautiful car we were we were missing I
think if Dan had said like why you want
a space where I'd want to time travel I
think he could have no Spencer arguing
here's why it's dangerous and scary and
I didn't hear a counter-argument he did
say was cool he said time travel is cool
let's go the fans cuz I this is
important this is for the marbles fans
thoughts chiming quick we're clicking
you're wearing because time travel and
in broke-ass car I love it moody
I'm the DeLorean doesn't even look that
nice from the outside so you it's a
Spencer Spencer had a better argument
hands down okay how come tell me why no
don't just say that will give me a
reason why well he gave better reasons
as to where it you can actually drive
that card you're not gonna f up
anybody's past or future so okay or
screw your mom like at some of your bike
might Lamar spin eg cuz it's about the
look alright we both interesting alright
so it comes unto me but the fans and the
couch are all leaning towards Spencer
yeah I mean it's interesting to me cuz I
think Dan it's a cool I think it is a
cool car you're being unfair that
Spencer but yet it's the faculty point
out it's a crappy car it [ __ ] up
space-time companion you want to show
off you went a little creative there
which is risky
but I have to reward the risk and I got
to go with the consensus I can't believe
this is happening I can't Spencer just
cut the point
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry we did it is what it is
Spencer just got the belt Spencer are
you surprised I'm shocked
I'm in complete shock right now if this
feels wrong but I can be used to it
well Spencer you are now the movie
fights champion for I will see how
that's yeah I'll play with that me I'm
put on the line any time Dan any time we
can we can we not wake up ten months
before the new edition of life I want
that belt we gonna make this you get to
fight now I'm excited for this actually
challenging you Mike are you gonna
challenge him to Spencer yeah Dan yeah
Mike Carlson Spencer Jake Gilbert uh
knows where you are at Spencer Jade
Gilbert oh crap
dan Merlin Merlin I know you're gonna be
mad at me I'm sorry
listen Spenny played a good game you
accepted the interview accepted and we
both made our arguments and that's how
the game is played
Thank You sold Sam I'm sure the fans at
home have their opinion anyway I love
our fans there will be some shock ball
hate Miller lawn Harris a lot of
headlines on Twitter Bravo the fans are
just upset I imagine
it's a good mix between like I can't
believe it and rigged not rigged hi
thank you Mike I got it dan it's not
rigged what can we at least agree it's
not rigged the question may not have
been fair but it's not rigged come on I
love that it wasn't just for me it's not
true dad I love to smoke was that joke I
love you Christian that's a very good
show and you have earned that belt sir
good for you
Ives a legit show I have look I just I
like to rub Christian the wrong way it's
not good I lost fair and square
I think Mike over there Mike Bravo job
the fans I felt like it changed not only
it changed your judging it changed how
the fighters of those they really became
are now so Michael anything you'd like
to plug your harvard-westlake debate
club yeah almost like debate team that's
it yeah Bravo sir that was a lot of
funny boxing and I got to thank our fans
quickly where the longest show ever but
that was that worth it was that good oh
this was the best and angry Dan is all I
see it live it
thank you guys moody dizzle dakota mr
you guys are awesome thank you so much
for your support I'm glad you got to we
got some have some witnesses here
because this is gonna go down
historically and we'll see how the books
are read written because I know there's
gonna be some talk about this one but
man thank you all for watching that was
an amazing live show our biggest ever I
hope you liked it and get excited
because we will be doing this more live
on Thursdays this man is pissed he wants
that belt back I'm excited to see what
that means actually so I'm gonna I love
that I'm sad for him but I love that
he's gonna come back strong I know he's
gonna and Spencer my god Wow shocker
Mike Carlson